OKAY GOOD MORNING --
GLAD TO SEE EVERYONE HERE --
WE WILL BE STARTING WITH THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR MEDIAN NOW --
BUT I THINK WE'LL DO.
ALL THE ROLE.
CENTER DORADO YES CENTER NIELSEN
CENTER NUMBER.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU SO WELCOME
EVERYONE --
LOOKING FORWARD TO TODAY'S
DISCUSSION.
WELL WE KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE
LIKE HOUSING ARE VERY VERY
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING THE STATE.
AND ALSO MORE POORLY WHAT'S
GOING TO BE OUR OUR RESPONSE TO
THEM.
AND IT'S GOING TO GIVE US A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED RESPONSE DOES THE I'M
GOING HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS.
WE WILL HEAR THE BUDGET ISSUES
RELATED TO THE GOVERNOR'S UP
PROPOSALS AS WELL AS PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING --
SO I THINK FIRST WE THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS --
AND THEN MOVE FROM THERE SO ON
THE VOTE ONLY MOTIONS.
OF WE I THINK WE WILL TAKE UP
ISSUES ONE TWO THREE AND SIX
SEPARATELY FROM THE OTHER.
ISSUES SO I NEED A MOTION OF ON
THOSE ISSUES [inaudible]
SECOND GAME.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF ISSUES ONE
TWO THREE AND SIX SO. TO DO BY
AND COMMENTING OKAY HOW MY NAME
PLEASE.
THERE ALSO YES NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
OKAY AND NOW WILL TAKE AS A
SEPARATE MOTION ISSUES FOR FIVE
AND SEVEN HERE MOTION.
OF SOME OF OF OUR ROLE.
YOUR OTHER CALL.
UP YES NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
AND WHAT I WAS THINKING OF I
KNOW YOUR CENTER I'M BURKE TIGHT
ON TIME JUST SO THAT WE DON'T.
FACE THAT AT THE END CAN WE FAST
FORWARD SENATOR NIELSEN --
TO ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY AND TAKE THAT UP BECAUSE
THAT IS ANOTHER BOAT ITEM THE
OTHERS ARE --
JUST TO JUST TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS -- SO
LET'S LET'S TAKE UP ISSUE TWENTY
AND LOOK OUT OF ORDER HERE.
ON ASK FOR A DEPARTMENT
PRESENTATION.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS THE MAIN THING ACOSTA
DEALING WITH EIGHTY BUDGET
OFFICE IS THAT [inaudible]
MAYBE CLOSER.
MARCH DIVERSE THEN DEPUTY
DIRECTING DEBBIE DIRECTOR FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING.
AND DANIEL BRANDON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
OKAY.
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
MIGRATORY AGRICULTURE WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF MY GOT SERVICES
PROGRAM BENEFITS NOT ONLY SENATE
RESIDENTS BUT ALSO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE.
MANY OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL CROPS
REMAIN LABOR INTENSIVE DURING
PEAK HARVESTING PERIODS WHICH
CREATES A GREATER PRESSURE FOR
LOCAL HOUSING AND ALL
AGRICULTURAL AREAS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS HOUSING DEMAND USUALLY FAR
EXCEEDS THE EXISTING RULE
HOUSING SUPPLY THIS FARMWORKERS
IN THE FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED TO
FIND ALTERNATIVE.
LESS DESIRABLE MEANS OF
TEMPORARY HOUSING WHILE WORKING
IN THE AREA.
THIS THESE ALTERNATIVES OFF THE
RESULT AND CENTER IN AND SEE
HOUSING CONDITIONS FOR WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
PROVIDING SAFE HEALTHY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS BENEFITS NOT ONLY
WORKERS THEMSELVES BUT ALSO THE
FARMERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION AT LARGE.
IT TO THE REQUEST THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO ADDRESS
HEALTH AND SAFETY DEFICIENCIES
AT STATE OWNED AGRICULTURAL
MIGRANT HOUSING CENTERS.
OKAY.
YEAH YES.
WHICH COUNTIES ARE THESE
DISPERSED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE.
PARTICULAR CENTERS THAT REQUIRE
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE YOU
KNOW WHAT COUNTIES.
THEY ARE THERE THERE'S TWENTY
FOUR CENTERS SO THEY ALL REQUIRE
SOME DEFERRED OR JUST SOME ARE
GOING TO GET THE DEFERRED.
US IN THIS CASE THAT'S NOT MUCH
MONEY FOR THAT MANY.
WE DID IT WE DID A NEEDS
ANALYSIS OF THE VARIOUS REPAIRS.
THIS THE TOTAL IS ABOUT NINE
MILLION FOR THESE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE THE WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
THEY REALLY NEED TO GO VERY SOON.
SO -- WE ARE
PRIORITIZING THOSE AND THIS THE
APPROPRIATION THAT WE ARE
SEEKING WILL TAKE CARE THOSE OF
THREE DIFFERENT CENTERS.
AND THEY'RE ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND I TRUST WHEN HE FOR SENATOR
THROUGHOUT CAL NO NO BUT THAT
THE ONES THAT ARE PRIORITIZE TO
THE MOST NEEDY AND THEIR AND
DIFFERENT COUNTIES RIGHT AROUND
ONE COUNTY [inaudible]
JOINING --
WELL I WILL LOOK AT THAT WE WILL
JUST GET BACK.
TO THANK YOU.
WELL THE MEASURE --
DO ANY.
THE FINANCE AND THE LA --
ANYMORE COMMENTS.
ALICE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION APPROACH PROVIDES
THE LEGISLATURE WITH ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT SEEMS REASONABLE.
OKAY COLLEAGUES CENTER ON BURKE.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
I HAVE A I HAVE A ADDITIONAL
QUESTION --
THIS IS COME UP BEFORE AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES --
HOW DO YOU INTEND TO ADDRESS THE
REST OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS?
IN THE CENTERS.
WE HAVE SOME FUNDING AVAILABLE
FROM PROPOSITION ONE SEE THE
LAST HOUSING BOND NOT A LOT LEFT
THAT WE WILL.
BE ABLE TO TAP A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT --
GOING FORWARD --
WE WILL LOOK AT OTHER OPTIONS
THE MAYBE THAT IN THE FUTURE
YOUR WOULD COME BACK FOR A
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION --
UNDER SB TO THE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING 10% OF IT HAS TO BE
SPENT FOR FARMWORKERS HOUSING SO
THAT MIGHT BE ONE OPTION WE
COULD USE AS WELL --
AND THEN THERE THERE ARE SOME
ABILITY TO TO SMALLER REPAIRS
WITH THE YOU KNOW WITH THE ON
GOING --
YEAH.
RENTAL INCOME THE COMES INTO
THAT'S VERY LIMITED BECAUSE OF
RENTS ARE EXTREMELY LOW BUT DO
WE WILL WE WILL LOOK FOR OTHER
OPTIONS GOING FORWARD FROM. ONE
OF THOSE TWO OR THREE SOURCES --
AND I JUST A QUESTION I KNOW
THESE ARE --
STATE --
HOUSING CENTERS.
ARE THESE THESE ARE STATE RUN
IT'S IT'S A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COUNTIES ARE OFTEN LIKE THE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES SO --
SORT OF THE STATE I THINK OWN
THE IMPROVEMENTS OFTEN THE
COUNTY ON THE LAND THE STATE
OWNS THE IMPROVEMENTS AND THEN.
THE THESE CENTERS ARE OPERATED
BY THE COUNTIES AND WE PRIDE
THERE'S A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION TO PROVIDE SOME
OPERATING SUPPORT EACH YEAR.
OKAY SO I JUST ONE ASSET --
JUST TO MAKE CLEAR THESE ARE NOT
WHAT --
GROWERS ARE AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE AS FAR AS
HOUSING NO YEAH THESE ARE PUBLIC
THESE ARE PUBLICLY FUNDED AND
PUBLICLY OWNED AND OPERATED
MIGRANT CENTERS OKAY AS ONE MAKE
SURE BECAUSE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYERS HAVE ESPECIALLY WITH
GUEST WORKERS.
SHOULD NOT IS NOT MIXED IN HERE
RIGHT AT MINOR RIGHT AT HOUSING
AND I UNDERSTAND AND THE THE THE
VISA ISSUES THAT THE EMPLOYER
HAS TO PROVIDE THE HOUSING RIGHT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
FUNDING WAS AN OVERLAPPING WITH
THAT THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
OKAY -- I
pTHERE'S WATSONVILLE AND DIXON
ARE TO THE CENTERS THERE WOULD
BE GETTING THOSE REPAIRS --
IT MIGHT BE JUST THOSE BE THAT --
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES AT THE
DIXON CENTER LOOKS LIKE ANOTHER
TO THEIR TO CENTERS INDEX AND
THERE'S THE RAM INMIGRANTES
CENTER AND THE DAVIS MIGRANTS
CENTER -- OR
AT LEAST INYO COUNTY SO.
OKAY -- CAN
WE HAVE A MOTION.
I'M SORRY I DO ALSO CARRY YES
OKAY [inaudible]
BROKEN.
YOU'RE ALSO YES NIELSEN.
NUMBER YES GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
NOW WE CAN LEARN.
GO BACK TO THE ORDER.
UNDER --
ISSUE EIGHT THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
MORNING.
MORNING GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KAREN
BAKER AND I'M THE CHIEF SERVICE
OFFICER OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR.
MORGAN W. DIRECTOR GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE PLAN RESEARCH THANKS
REVENUE.
I'M I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND BEGIN --
BY SEEING HIM ALSO JOINED HERE
TODAY --
BITE SHEILA BOXLEY.
WHO IS THE?
THESE PREVENTION CENTER AND ONE
OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS FIFTY
TWO GRANTEES.
AND THEN THE MOMENT SHE'S ABLE
TO CERTAINLY SHARE HER FIRST
HAND INSIGHTS.
ON WHAT IT MEANS TO UTILIZE THE
AMERICORPS RESOURCES WHILE
ADDRESSING A COMMUNITY NEED BUT
BEFORE THAT I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
KIND OF A GLIMPSE INTO
AMERICORPS CALIFORNIA --
AMERICORPS FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
MAY NOT IT IS OR WHAT WHO WE ARE
IS OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
DOMESTIC PEACE CORPS --
INDIVIDUALS OF OF ALL AGES BUT
USUALLY BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE ARE
PLACED IN NON PROFITS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
AND AS AMERICORPS MEMBERS
THEY'RE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY SERVE THEIR COUNTRY.
IN EITHER A FULL TIME OR PART
TIME CAPACITY IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
AMERICORPS MEMBERS THEY'RE ABLE
TO PLAY A REALLY MEANINGFUL ROLE
IN ADDRESSING A WIDE RANGE OF
COMMUNITY NEEDS.
WHETHER IT'S THE OVER ONE
HUNDRED AMERICORPS MEMBERS WHO
SERVED IN PARADISE DURING THE
RECENT FIRES SOME OF WHOM ARE
STILL THERE.
OR CITY OR MEMBERS IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS WHO SHOW UP EVERY DAY TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
CLOSE THE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
GAP OR AMERICORPS MEMBERS
SERVING IN ORANGE COUNTY.
WHO SERVE IN A CLUSTER OF FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS PROVIDING
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
STRENGTHENING ACTIVITIES?
WE HAVE AMERICORPS MEMBERS
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR VETERANS
THE HOMELESS FOR FOSTER YOU.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS ENGAGED IN
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
EFFORTS AND HELPING LOW INCOME
FAMILIES NAVIGATE THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
EFFECTIVELY OVERSEAS OVER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
ANNUALLY.
AND WHILE WE ARE INSPIRED BY
THIS WORK THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DONE.
WE CAN'T HELP BUT BE FRUSTRATED
BY THE FACT THAT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS WHY WE STAND READY. TO
PROVIDE DESPERATELY NEEDED RE
THANK NOT BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE GRANTS IN THE PAST SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY LACK THE MATCH
FUNDING NEEDED TO SECURE AN
AMERICORPS GRANT.
WITH THE PROPOSED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDS OUR INTENTION
IS TO INVEST TEN MILLION OF
THESE FUNDS INTO CREATING
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS WITH NON
PROFITS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHO ARE YEARNING TO HAVE
AMERICORPS MEMBERS?
WE SEE THIS AS THE FIRST STEP.
TO EXPAND AMERICORPS TO A TOTAL
OF TEN THOUSAND AMERICORPS
MEMBERS STATEWIDE.
THE SECOND TEN MILLION WILL BE
USED TO AUGMENT THE CURRENT
EDUCATION AWARD.
THAT FULL TIME MEMBERS RECEIVE.
THE THEY CURRENTLY RECEIVE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE LIKE TO TAKE THAT TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MEMBER.
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
DEBT I THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON.
AND WE PROPOSE THAT ONE WAY TO
PAY DOWN OUR PROPORTION OF THIS
DAD IS TO ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE
WILLING TO GIVE A YEAR OF THEIR
LIFE.
IN SERVICE TO HIGH NEED
CALIFORNIANS.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT
AMERICORPS MEMBERS THE TAKE
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND BECOME A
PART OF THE NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
SECTOR?
WORKFORCE AND IN THE OR GO INTO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND DEVOTE
THEIR TIME TO VOLUNTEERING IN A
REALLY ROBUST WAY.
IN THE END AMERICORPS MEETS
COMMUNITY NEEDS BY ADDING
CAPACITY TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE ON THE GROUND.
DOING THE HARD WORK DAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
IT CREATES A MODE OF WORK FORCED
PERSON AND IT ACTUALLY SAVES
TAXPAYER DOLLARS I PROVIDING
EFFICIENT SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF
OUR MOST CHALLENGING PUBLIC
NEEDS.
BUT ABOVE ALL AMERICORPS UNITES
CALIFORNIANS IN SERVICE.
AS MANY VETERANS WILL TELL YOU.
ALTHOUGH THE SERVICEMAN OR WOMAN
STANDING NEXT YOU MAY LOOK
DIFFERENT FROM YOU OR COME FROM
A DIFFERENT BACKGROUND.
SERVING TOGETHER CONNECTION IN A
FUNDAMENTAL WAY.
AND ENDED IN IN A DAY AND AGE
WHERE OUR SOCIETY IS BECOMING
MORE AND MORE FRACTURED WE ARE
CALLED T INVEST IN
OPPORTUNITIES THE BRING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER THE MAKES
A STRONGER AND THAT UNITE US.
AGAIN ABOUT HOW THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS I JUST REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BEFORE WE WILL BONTA --
QUESTIONS --
FINANCE AND LA --
NOW COMES.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRIAN YOU ARE
WITH THE LA --
OF WHAT WE THINK THE PROPOSAL
GENERALLY IS WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WE THINK THAT THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER SOME
MODIFICATIONS TO THE STRUCTURE
OF THE PROPOSAL IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT.
THAT IT IS BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE THE FIRST
STEP IN A GREATER EXPANSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS.
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR --
AS WAS MENTIONED --
THAT THERE'S A NG FUND
REQUIREMENT FOR THESE FUNDS AS
COMPARED TO THE EXISTING PROGRAM
THE MATCHING FUNDS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PUT FORWARD BY
THESE.
NEW GRANTEES WOULD BE LOWER THAN
HAS TRADITIONALLY BEEN TRUE WITH
THIS PROGRAM IN WALL THERE MAY
BE ARGUMENTS --
THAT THAT COULD BE NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO ENCOURAGE A GRANTEES TO
FORM PROGRAMS AND AREAS WHERE
THEY DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THIS --
IS BEING VIEWED AS A FIRST STEP
TOWARDS GREATER EXPANSION OF
THIS MIGHT BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE TO TEST OUT.
WHAT KIND OF MODELS COULD WORK
FOR GREATER EXPANSION IN IN
PARTICULAR TESTING OUT WHETHER
IF WE STICK WITH THE EXISTING
MATCHING?
WOULD THERE BE WITH THEIR STILL
BE ENOUGH DEMAND AMONG GRANTEES
TO FORM NEW PROGRAMS IN A FOR
THAT WERE THE CASE.
THEN THE STATE'S DOLLARS TOWARDS
A GREATER EXPANSION WOULD GO
FURTHER --
IN COULD CREATE MORE SLOTS IN
THE FUTURE.
IF -- THE
MATCHING FUNDS WERE A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER ON THE LOCAL LEVEL SO
IT'S SOMETHING TO CONSIDER
MOVING FORWARD.
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT SURE.
SO I'VE BEEN IN THIS POSITION
FOR TWELVE YEARS.
WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY HAD
PRIORITY POINTS GIVEN TO THOSE
COUNTIES THOSE YOU OFTEN TEND
COUNTIES.
THAT ARE UNABLE TO PUT FORWARD A
GRANT THAT EVER GETS FUNDED.
AND THE REASON THEY DON'T GET
FUNDED IT BECAUSE IS BECAUSE
SIMPLY THERE ARE NOT MATCH
DOLLARS AVAILABLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
SO I'VE GOT.
LIKE LIVING EXPERIENCE OF THIS.
AND SO SO I WOULD ARGUE TO
REALLY TACKLE THIS IS TO
RECOGNIZE.
AS WE HAVE THAT IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES YOU NEED TO KICK
START THIS YOU NEED TO BOTH
DEVELOP THAT OPERATIONAL
CAPABILITY OF NONPROFITS AND SAY
WE'RE GOING TO AUGMENT THIS A
BIT.
OKAY TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN GET
THIS STARTED AND REALLY ADDRESS
CRITICAL NEEDS IN YOUR COMMUNITY
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
CENTRAL VALLEY NEEDS THESE KINDS
OF RESOURCES.
YOU'VE GOT HIGHER POVERTY RATES
YOU'VE GOT JUST REALLY
ENTRENCHED ISSUES AND NOT ENOUGHSTRONG NON PROFITS THEY CAN
WRITE COMPETITIVE AMERICORPS
GRANTS TO SECURE THE FUNDS THEY
NEED.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO KIND OF SOLVE FOR ANNA ALSO
COMMENT THAT WE HAVE RUN THIS BY
ISSUE A BOX WE CAN ATTEST.
BY THE GROUP OF CURRENT GRANT
TEASE TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND.
OUR STRATEGY FOR THIS AND THEY
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS EVEN
THOUGH THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
IS ADDITIONAL FUNDS BEING GIVEN.
TO THIS DESERT OF SERVICE IN THE
MIDDLE OF OUR STATE THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDS THESE KINDS OF
RESOURCES.
AND WE NEED PEOPLE WITH IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO SERVE THEIR
FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES.
DIRECTOR IDEA CERTAINLY HAVE A
SYMPATHY BECAUSE I AM ORIGINALLY
FROM IN FRONT FORMED THE CENTRAL
VALLEY RIGHT BUT I MUST ADMIT.
THERE ARE OTHER VALLEY'S.
THAT SHOULD HAVE EQUAL STANDING
THAT HAVE EQUAL PROBLEMS
COACHELLA SACRAMENTO HAS KICKED
TO THE NORTH SACRAMENTO ABOUT.
AND DID.
SOME CONCERN TO ME THAT YOUR
FOCUS SO MUCH JUST ON THE QUOTE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHAT ABOUT OTHER AREAS I KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE PEOPLE BEING UP
IN PARADISE YEAH HUNDRED OF THEM
DEVASTATED AREA HONOR THAT'S
PARADISE ON SENATOR OF COURSE
GOT FOLKS UP THERE BUT?
I HATE TO SEE OTHERS EXCLUDED.
AND THAT IS COMMON IN EQUITY
BECAUSE SOME OF THE COUNTIES
ALREADY.
AS TO THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
THE HIGHER COST YEAR THAN THOSE
WHO ARE COMING IN I THEY DON'T
MIND THAT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IN BUTTE COUNTY --
IT HAS POINT 6% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION BUT POINT 2% OF OUR
AMERICORPS.
RESOURCE SAID THEY ARE ACTUALLY.
THEY HAVE A HIGHER THAN
POPULATION PERCENTAGE OF
AMERICORPS SLOTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BENEFIT FROM.
THE EXPANSION OF THIS PROGRAM
THE PARADISE FOLKS ARE NOT GOING
TO PERMIT NO NO NO NO I'M I'M
JUST LETTING YOU KNOW AS A
COUNTY THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SERVE.
AND AND THERE ARE THERE ARE SO
MANY NEEDY COUNTIES FOR THIS
RESOURCE.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU SIR WE
WE COULD AND SHOULD EXPAND THIS
TO ALL HIGH NEED COUNTIES YOU
KNOW HOWEVER WE WOULD WANTED TO
FIND THIS.
I THINK THIS WAS AN EFFORT ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PARTED REALLY
JUST TAKE.
A LOOK AT A DECADES LONG PROB
PROBLEM OF A LACK OF INVESTMENT
A LACK OF CAPABILITY FROM ANY
NON PROFITS IN THAT COMMUNITY
AND SHEILA BOX WE CAN SPEAK AS
SOMEONE WHO IS.
WHO'S TRIED --
TO PLACE PROGRAMS IN THAT
COMMUNITY AND THESE THESE THIS-DESERT.
AND HER CHALLENGES IN RAISING
MATCH IT'S JUST BEEN SIGNIFICANT
BUT I DON'T DISAGREE THERE'S
OTHER NEEDS THAT ARE GOING ON
THAT. TO YOUR POINT.
BUT LET ME ASK ANALYST IS THAT.
AS WE BUILD P. WEISS WE'RE
CREATING FUTURE [inaudible]
BUDGET OBLIGATIONS.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO DO SO MUCH.
BUT TOO MANY TIMES CALIFORNIA
DOES A GO IT ALONE OR GO BEYOND
THE FEDERAL AND THAT DOESN'T
THAT IMPACT OUR BUDGET TO SOME.
SIGNIFICANT DEGREE ON OCCASION
COULD THAT NOT BE THE CASE HERE.
WE HAVE A KIND OF A CALIFORNIA
LOAN PROGRAM.
I'M NOT.
SURE THAT THIS PROPOSED
EXPANSION IS NECESSARILY
CREATING KIND OF PERMANENT ANG
GOING POSITIONS --
IT WOULD BE COULD KIND OF KICK
STARTING THESE NEW PROGRAMS --
THAT WOULD HAVE A DEFINED
TIMELINE AND AND THEN IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WERE PROVIDED
IN THE FUTURE --
THAN THEY COULD CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD BUT I THINK THIS MONEY
IS FOR KIND OF A DEFINED PROGRAM
WITH A DEFINED.
TIME I KNOW YOU I MEAN I GUESS
IT'S ANOTHER QUESTION OF WHETHER
OR NOT --
PUTTING THIS FUNDING OUT THERE
IN PARTICULAR SOME OF THE
PARAMETERS AROUND THE LOCAL
MATCH OTHER THINGS WHETHER OR
NOT THAT CHANGES KIND OF THE
PRESIDENT.
MOVING FORWARD THE GRANTEES WILL
EXPECT -- I
THINK THAT THAT'S AN OPEN
QUESTION AND ONE THAT ARE GOING
TO BE.
LIMITED TERM P. WISE OR
PERMANENT P. WISE BECAUSE THAT'S
IMPORTANT RIGHT THERE THEY'RE
NOT SPECIFICALLY P. WISE ITS
INVESTMENT --
TO IT IS ONE YEAR FUNDING THAT
CAN BE SPENT OVER A TWO YEAR
PERIOD AND PERHAPS WELL I GOT IT
RIGHT HE WISE IS WHAT I CAN I
KNOW I HEAR YEAH I HEAR YEAH HE
NEEDS YEAH.
BOB AGREES SOURCES STATE RIGHT.
I WANT TO ALSO LET YOU KNOW
THOUGH YOU YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT MENTION CALIFORNIA IS
NOT THE ONLY STATE DURING THIS.
MINNESOTA INVEST OVER TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THESE KINDS
OF STRATEGIES THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON INVEST DOLLARS SO SO
IF ANYTHING WERE A LITTLE LATE
TO THE GAME WERE USUALLY LEAD IN
THIS AREA WHERE THE LARGEST
AMERICORPS PROGRAM.
IN THE NATION I WOULD ARGUE THE
MOST A FACT --
IF YOU ASK ME.
I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
JUST SIMPLY RECOGNIZE THAT FOR
THAT THERE'S THERE'S GAPS THAT
WE THINK WE NEED TO KICK START
AND IT IS STARTUP MONEY AND AS
THE GOVERNOR HAS ALSO PROPOSED.
I WILL BE WORKING QUITE ACTIVELY
WITH PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY. TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
RAISED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE VERY KEENLY INTERESTED
IN THIS.
THANK YOU --
FIRST OF ALL WHAT WHAT A
WONDERFUL MISSION YES ISN'T IT
GREAT.
NUMBER TWO IS DUE TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN ENCOURAGE THE KIND
OF DIVERSITY --
THAT THAT.
PROVIDES BENEFITS TO BOTH THE
THE PERSON TO SPENDING ALL OF US
YOU KNOW LET LET US KNOW HOW WE
DO IT.
NUMBER THREE A QUESTION --
SO THE THE ANNUAL STIPEND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND IF THIS IF IF
WE APPROVE THIS BUDGET MEASURED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PER.
AMERICORPS VOLUNTEER NO SO OKAY
SO WHAT WHAT GETS COMPLICATED ON
THE NUMBERS AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE HOW RIDICULOUSLY
COMPLICATED --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS MADE
THIS FOR US ALL.
RIGHT BUT THE CHALLENGE HERE.
IS THAT AN APPLICANT'S TEARS OF
WHAT THEY INTEND ON PAIN.
THE AM AMERICORPS MEMBER THERE
IS A RANGE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO PAY WHICH
RANGES FROM 1-300-022-0000 AS
FAR AS OUR CONTRIBUTION.
TYPICALLY TO THAT STATEMENT SOME
PROGRAMS DEPEND BECAUSE OF THE
HOUSING REALITIES LIKE A SAN
FRANCISCO JUSTICE CORPS MEMBER.
THEY WILL RAISE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO PAY UP TO TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO COVER A
STIPEND SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE A
SHARED APARTMENT WITH THREE
OTHER PEOPLE.
RIGHT BECAUSE OF THAT JUST THE
LIVING COSTS REALITY FOR THAT.
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL WERE PROPOSING TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MEMBER.
UNDER FOR TO BE PROVIDED AS
STIPEND.
AND RECOGNIZING FOR AN ANNUAL
YES THE YES MA'AM FOR A FULL
FULL TIME MEMBER.
SO WHAT WHAT'S THE RANGING
CALIFORNIA.
SO YOU HAVE SOME PROGRAMS THAT
FOR THAT ARE ONLY REQUESTING.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND THOSE ARE
USUALLY IN MARKETS WHERE YOU
HAVE LET'S SAY A SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT IS PROVIDING MATCH.
THAT HAS A PRIVATE CORPORATIONS
THAT PROVIDE A LOT OF MATCH SO
IN SOME PROGRAMS YOU HAVE ONLY
ONE THIRD OF THE PROGRAM COSTS.
COMING THE JUSTICES SO GIVE ME
THE LOWEST AND GIVE ME THE
HIGHEST LOS IS THIRTEEN THE
HIGHEST IS.
TWENTY OKAY YEAH IN AND WHAT WE
TEND TO SEE IS THAT HIGHER
NUMBER IS NEEDED IN EITHER HIGH
PRICED MARKETS OR IN THOSE
MARKETS WHERE THERE IS NO MATCH
FOR LIMITED MATCH AVAILABLE HE
RIGHT SO IF THIS GETS APPROVED
YEAH DOES THAT CHANGE THAT AT
ALL.
NO.
IT'S NOT A POLICY CHANGE AT ALL.
DOES THEM UP IT BEYOND NO NO NO
NO NO.
IS THE DEBT FORGIVENESS COLLEGE
DEBT FORGIVENESS YEAH WHAT'S
WHAT'S EXCITING IS DURING YOUR
YEAR OF SERVICE YOUR THERE IS
YOU DON'T PAY AGAINST YOUR
STUDENT LOAN FOR THE YEAR OF
YOUR SERVICE.
AND THEN YOU'RE GIVEN THIS
EDUCATION AWARD ON THE BACK END
OF YOUR SERVICE.
IN A SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR IN
EDUCATION AWARD. SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS TO AUGMENT THAT
WITH AN ADDITIONAL.
CLOSE TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO THAT WE CAN IN ESSENCE BE
PROVIDING TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A YEAR OF SERVICE THAT'S
WHEN TRYING TO GET HER BACK OKAY
SO S. WHATEVER THAT SPIKE
WHATEVER THAT.
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY THOUSAND
CORRECT LOS.
MAXIMUM OF TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN DEBT YES YES YES.
YES.
OUR THE FOR THE QUESTIONS.
OKAY DID YOU WANT MISS BOXLEY I
THINK SHE CAN GIVE SOME REALLY
COMPELLING SUPPORT SO IF YOU
HAVE A FEW MOMENTS WE CAN DO
THAT BE GREAT THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
YES.
GOOD MORNING I'M SHEILA BOXLEY
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO AND
HAVE BEEN FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER WHICH IS.
A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION REALLY
FOCUSED ON CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION --
DEEP INTO COMMUNITIES AND
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES.
I'M WE HAVE BEEN UTILIZING
AMERICORPS MEMBERS IN FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS IN EARLY
EDUCATION AND WORKING WITH
FOSTER CARE IN DOING HOME
VISITATION.
VERY EFFECTIVELY SINCE AMERICA
CORPS FIRST BEGAN SO FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT.
AND WHAT I WANT YOU TO KNOW IS
PARTICULARLY IN THE PREVENTION
ARENA.
WITH A NUMBER OF AMERICORPS
MEMBERS CURRENTLY SERVING THAT
IS REALLY A FOUNDATION FOR CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION AND THE STATE
UNLIKE ANY OTHER STATE SO IT'S
QUITE CRITICAL TO THE WORK THAT
WE DO TO SUPPORT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS. FOR A
PREVENTION PROGRAM BE AT HOME
VISITATION OR AND FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS IT COST US
ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
TO WORK INTENSIVELY WITH THE
FAMILY 97% OF THOSE FAMILIES DO
NOT EVER ENTER TRIAL WELFARE
SYSTEM.
A FAMILY THAT DOES INTO THAT
SYSTEM AVERAGE COST OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD INVESTMENT
IN OUR FAMILIES AND OUR CHILDREN
IN OUR STATE --
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING.
DESPERATELY TO HAVE MORE
RESOURCES INTO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE'S HIGH NEED IF YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THE DATA AND
SOME OF THOSE COUNTIES IN TERMS
OF MY AREA OF OF PROGRAMMING.
YOU'LL SEE THERE SOME SOME VERY
FRIGHTENING NUMBERS IN TERMS OF
THE LEVEL OF CHILD POVERTY IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE.
ON IN TERMS OF THE ALLEGATIONS
OF CHILD ABUSE HOWEVER WE SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE PARTNERS THERE WHO
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE MATCH SO WE'RE NOT
ADEQUATELY PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES ARE THESE ARE REALLY
CORE FUNDAMENTAL SERVICES.
THAT I BELIEVE ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE WHOLE
PUBLIC TO TO PROVIDE --
I ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW A COUPLE
OF OTHER THINGS ONE IS WE WE
PRETTY MUCH EXCLUSIVELY RECRUIT
AMERICORPS MEMBERS FROM DEEP
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
SERVING.
SO THEY REPRESENT THE CULTURAL
THE LINGUISTIC MAKE UP OF THAT
COMMUNITY.
AFTER THEIR TERM OF SERVICE
WHICH IN OUR CASE IS USUALLY
SEVERAL YEARS BECAUSE THEY CAN
RE UP AND THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
DO SERVICE --
THEY STAY IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THEY'VE BEEN TRAINED THEIR
ONGOING ASSET AND ROLE MODEL IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
AND WE SEE THAT THEY GO ON TO BE
LEADERS WE SEE THAT THEY GO ON
TO TAKE THAT AND AWARD AND
BECOME LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS OR TEACHERS OR SOMETHING
ELSE IN THE HELPING FIELD.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY BUILDING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AND DARE I SAY WE'RE
TRAINING PEOPLE TO BE READY FOR
THE WORK FORCE AS WELL AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS MUCH --
I DO WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ON THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PERHAPS
DISPROPORTIONATE MATCH THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED TO PROJECTS.
I AM THE CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA MIRACLE REPRESENT ALL
OF THE AMERICORPS PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE.
AND OUR STEERING COMMITTEE MET
RECENTLY I THINK ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AGO.
LOOK AT THIS LANGUAGE AND
DISCUSSED IT AND WE ARE IN TOTAL
SUPPORT SO THAT IS THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT WHAT WE ARE ALSO VERY
EXCITED ABOUT IS THE INCREASE IN
THE MATCH DOLLARS IS GOING TO
ALSO HELP US IN RECRUITING
PEOPLE --
EFFECTIVELY AND RETAINING THEM
BECAUSE THAT'S A HUGE ASSET A
YES IT'S A FOUR THOUSAND DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE BUT A FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND A FROZEN STUDENT
LOAN.
IS IS A BIG DEAL AND SINCE MOST
OF OUR MEMBERS SERVE AT LEAST
TWO YEARS WE'RE TALKING TWENTY
THOUSAND SO WITH AN AVERAGE DEBT
OF THIRTY THREE THOUSAND THAT'S
A PRETTY BIG TRUCK TO BE ABLE TO
TO ADDRESS FOR THEM.
AND REALLY CHANGE THEIR
PROJECTION OF THE THEIR LIFE FOR
THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE THINK
THAT'S QUITE QUITE IMPORTANT SO
WE HAVE --
ENDORSE THAT WE ARE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY BEHIND IT AND WE WE
THINK THAT YOU COULD DO EVEN
MORE AND MORE BECAUSE THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT WAY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES COST EFFICIENTLY.
BUT EFFECTIVELY WHILE ENGAGING
THE COMMUNITIES WHO NEED THE
SERVICES NOT DROPPING INTO DOING
SOMETHING FOR THEM AND THEN
WALKING AWAY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
COLLEAGUES NUMBER --
AND AND I TAKE YOUR POINT ABOUT
DEVELOPING LEADERS IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY BOTH RECRUITING AND
EATING THE LEADERSHIP SORT OF
POPULATION --
IN.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE DO THIS OR
HOW YOU DO THIS BUT I I DO THINK
THERE'S SOME VALUE OF TAKING A
YOUNG PERSON FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
AND HAVING THEM EXPOSED TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY --
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
MUTUAL BENEFIT THERE I'M NOT
SURE HOW WE HOW WE BALANCE THOSE.
TWO IMPORTANT GOALS BUT JUST
SOME THING TO THINK ABOUT IF I
CAN JUST MENTION AND SHE CHILTON
COMMENT ON THIS AS WELL.
PROGRAMS ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
RECRUITMENT --
OF THEIR MEMBERS SO WHAT'S --
INTERESTING IS THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT MAY CHOOSE TO
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON RECRUITS FROM
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
AND OTHERS THAT RECRUITS
STATEWIDE OR EVEN NATIONALLY SO
THAT ISN'T A REQUIREMENT THAT IT
COME FROM THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
BUT WE OFTEN SEE THAT.
ON THAT THE COUNTY THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT OFTEN CAN
ATTRACT.
YOU KNOW --
OPPORTUNITIES FROM THAT LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU CAN FIND AT
NIGHTAND I TAKE YOUR POINT YEAH
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF VALUE IN
THERE'S JUST THERE'S DEPENDS ON
YEAH BUT I AGREE WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY IF THAT WOULD BE.
WE HAVE A LARGE CLUSTER OF
MEMBERS IN ORANGE COUNTY
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE
NETWORK OF FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS DOWN THERE --
PROVIDING SERVICES AND NOT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT WE RECRUIT IS
FROM WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY THERE
ARE OTHER PEOPLE WHO COME IN AND
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO TO HAVE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE REAL NEEDS OF
OTHER COMMUNITIES AND NOT.
JUST PERHAPS IN THEIR OWN THEIR
OWN WORLD BUT WHAT WE DO FIND IS
IN TERMS OF THE TRUST
PARTICULARLY VERY VULNERABLE
FAMILIES.
VERY OFTEN IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THAT PERSON TO KNOW THAT
COMMUNITY AND UNDERSTAND IT A
SIMPLE EXAMPLE IS.
HI THIS IS HOW YOU CAN GO ABOUT
GETTING THIS PARTICULAR SERVICE
THAT YOU NEED A WE'RE GOING TO
HELP YOU AND THIS IS WHERE IT IS.
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE TO BUST CHANGES AND
YOU HAVE AN INFANT AND A TODDLER --
JUST BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR ON THE
LIVE I CAN BE VERY AFFECT ALL
RIGHT THAT I I I AGAIN I TAKE
YOUR POINT I THINK.
IT SO ALL RIGHT SIDE OF THE
EQUATION THANK YOU COULD --
I THINK THIS IS ALL VERY VERY.
GOOD AND POSITIVE I COMMEND YOU
ON I THINK THIS IS A A GREAT
PROGRAM JUST ONE MORE QUESTION
TO BE.
A CLEAR ON SENATOR UMBERG'S --
QUESTION ON THE COLLEGE DEBT
FORGIVENESS YOU MENTIONED IT WAS
OF FEDERAL EDUCATION AWARD OR IS
IT FOR SENATE FEDERAL TRUST THAT
PROVIDE SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT
OF THE CORPORATION FOR NATIONAL
AND COMMUNITY SERVICE WHICH IS
THE FEDERAL AGENCY.
THAT OVERSEES THE TRUST THEY
PROVIDE THAT TO EVERY FULL TIME
AMERICORPS MEMBER THE COME.
A YEAR OF SERVICE.
SO THEY'RE CONSIDERED EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A FEDERAL PROGRAM.
AND OURS IS THE STATE AND ITS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA THAT THEY ARE
SELECTED.
YEAH HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU THAT ALL COME TOGETHER
HOW DOES IT COME TOGETHER
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL AWARD.
AND THE STATE SO GRANT FEDERAL
RESOURCE FOR THE FOR THE
AMERICORPS MEMBER OF THE STIPEND
ONCE THEY'RE SELECTED.
GRANT DOLLARS FLOW FROM THE
FEDERAL ENTITY INTO CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS.
COFFERS WE THEN HOLD A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS. SEVEN
SHEILA BOXLEY RECEIVES THE GRANT.
SHE ENTERS IN TO EAT GROUNDS
THAT THESE ARE HER MEMBERS AND
ONCE THEY COMPLETE THEIR SERVICE.
THAT INFORMATION GET SENT TO ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR SERVICE SO THEY QUALIFY
FOR OUR TRUST. SIX OUTSIDE YEAH
YEAH I JUST WANT TO MAKE JOHN
GLAD IT ALWAYS CONNECT THE DOTS
RIGHT AT THE TWO YEAH RIGHT SO
LIKE SOME CRACK WILL GET FOUR
THOUSAND AND SOMEONE GETS SICK
STYLE DOWN NOW.
YOU'LL GET THE TO GET TO
TOGETHER.
OKAY YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
ANNA.
SENATE COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
QUESTION.
OKAY -- I
THINK THAT --
FOR NOW OUR STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS TO HOLD IT OPEN SO --
BUT WE I I THINK I CAN ONLY
SPEAK FOR MYSELF.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM
AND I COMMEND YOU.
I THINK ARE YOU CAN.
YOU ARE YOUNGER WHOEVER
VOLUNTEERS I ASSUME A LOT OF
THEM ARE YOUNG.
IT'S A GREAT THING TO DO IN
THEIR LIFE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SAME [inaudible]
OKAY. NINE NINE OKAY ISSUE.
NINE DISCOUNT NINE WHICH IS I'M
SURE IS GOING TO BE THE MOST
EXCITING THE PRESENTATION --
HERE TODAY ON A PROPOSAL FOR A
FUNNY IN --
TO TO DEAL WITH THE FISCAL
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM --
WE REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS --
TO ESTABLISH THREE POSITIONS --
TO ASSIST WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM OF CALIFORNIA
KNOWN A FISH GO ON THIS IS
BASED ON THE INCREASED LEVEL OF
WORKING COMPLEXITY FISCAL
RELATED TO TASKS.
THAT HAVE INCREASED --
OVER THE LAST YEAR IN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO CREASE WITH WITH THE
AND TO SPEAK WITH --
OR TO SOME OF US STAFF COMMENTS --
THEY MENTIONED --
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES CLEARLY BE
BENEFICIAL DEPARTMENT.
OF THE PROPER LEVEL OF RESOURCES
LESS CLEAR IT'S SIMILAR GRANT
MAKING THE OPERATIONS.
TYPICALLY HAVE LARGER ACCOUNTING
AND FINANCE AND STATUS RELATIVE
TO SMALLER ORE ADMINISTRATIVE.
ENTITIES BECAUSE OPR HAS BOTH
GRANT MAKING AND RESEARCH AND
POLICY SECTIONS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF COUNTY AND FINANCE
RESOURCES UNCLEAR ABSENT
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD INFORMATION --
AND WE DON'T NECESSARILY
DISAGREE WITH THAT THOSE THOSE
STAFF COMMENTS --
WE DID BASED THE THREE POSITIONS
ON ON THE NEEDS THAT WE'VE SEEN
ON A WORK LOW LEVEL.
OVER THE FIRST YEAR OF BEING IN
THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS OUR NEED FOR
SEPARATION OF DUTIES --
AND THAT'S BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
WITH THE P. R. OVER THE YEARS
VERY SMALL ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
YOU KNOW ONE FULL TIME
ACCOUNTANT --
YOU KNOW ONE FULL TIME CONTRACT
PERSON DEDICATED THE THE APPEAR
PROGRAMS.
AND SO WHEN YOU WORK INSIDE
FISCAL THERE'S THERE'S A
REQUIRED SEPARATION OF DUTIES --
THAT THAT IS IS MUCH MORE
INVOLVED THAN THAN HAS BEEN IN
THE PAST.
AND SO THE THREE POSITIONS BOTH
BASED ON ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AS
WELL AS THAT NEED TO TO MEET THE
SEPARATION OF DUTIES
REQUIREMENTS --
FROM AN ACCOUNTING STANDPOINT
TRANSFERRED THE STANDPOINT IN IT
AND A CHANCE.
A TRANSITION TO THE NEW SYSTEM I
RELATED EVERYTHING FROM THE
PROCUREMENT TO THE COUNTY TO THE
TO THE GRANTS IN THE INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENTS WE HAVE TO ENTERTAIN
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
OKAY.
ABOUT FROM MAR FINANCE EARN
[inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS.
SERVICE DEPARTMENT FINANCE I
THINK AND I APPRECIATE THAT
APPEARS RECOGNIZING THAT --
THE WORKLOAD IS DOES EXIST I
THINK THAT THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
YOU'RE SEEN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
IN SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS FOR FIFTH
COLUMN WE JUST WANT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL MAKE SURE THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL.
WE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T KNOW ALL THE
PIECES THE COMPONENTS WOULD TO
ACTUALLY USING THE SYSTEM AND SO
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SET UP FOR SUCCESS.
THEY ALSO HAVE I'M TAKING ON A
LOT OF DIFFERENT SPECIAL
PROJECTS FOR THE GOVERNOR --
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO MEET ALL THE
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE'VE GIVEN
THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALEJO'S [inaudible]
COM [inaudible]
OKAY.
A QUICK QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
THE STATUS STABILIZATION WHAT'S
THE STATUS OF STABILIZATION.
IN FISCAL OF DISCUSSES HIMSELF
WELL IT IS STABILIZATION AMONG
THE UNITS AND SYSTEM ITSELF
RIGHT.
SO I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE GETTING TO
THAT THAT POINT THAT'S I MEAN
PART OF THE REASON FOR THESE
THREE POSITIONS IS TRY TO TO TO
TO GET TO THAT STABILIZE WORK --
WORKLOAD AND AGAIN TO THAT
SEPARATION OF DUTIES --
YOU KNOW ONE THING ABOUT THIS
GAL IS IT'S ALSO CONTINUALLY.
IMPROVING IF YOU WILL A NEW
MODELS COME ONLINE GUIDE NEW
TRAINING.
WHICH TAKES STAFF TIME AND ALSO
REQUIRES KIND OF SEE.
YOU KNOW A IT'S IT'S A IT'S A
SYSTEM THAT THAT ISN'T.
COMPLETELY FINALIZED FOR LACK OF
A BETTER TERM --
AND SO I YOU KNOW IT WE'RE IT
WOULD THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO HELP.
US STABILIZE INTERNALLY --
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT
LONG TERM.
WITH THE OVERALL START ANY UNITS%
STABILIZED.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH
YOU ANTICIPATE ANY UNITS BEING
STABILIZED IN THIS YEAR.
I DIED FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT
I DON'T KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN LOOK INTO AND GET BACK TO ME.
OKAY YEAH I HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T
REALLY LOOKED AT THAT THE
STABILIZATION OF OTHER UNITS OF
OUR THAT BE GREAT AND IF IF.
LATER ON THAT WHAT THE
DEFINITIONS OF STABILIZATION HOW
MANY UNITS ARE STABILIZED WHEN
DO YOU ANTICIPATE.
THE STABILIZATION SORT OF I
SUPPOSE THE SEQUENCE.
OKAY THANK GOD [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ALL RIGHT --
WORLD ALL HOLD OPENS ON THIS --
AWAY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY TOO MANY PEOPLE AFTER.
ALL HAVE TO CUT THE TIME DOWN.
NOT ALL AT ONCE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CERTAINLY APPRECIATED --
RULE ON TO ISSUE.
TEN SB TEN SEVENTY TWO
LIMITATION CORRECT --
SO -- OF
SPLINTER WEEK RESEARCH REQUEST
THREE POSITIONS AND THREE AND A
NINETY TO THE NINE FISCAL YEAR
TO IMPLEMENT SB.
TEN SEVENTY TWO WHICH REQUIRE
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSEL TO
COMPLETE THE FOLLOWING TEST
DEVELOPED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GUIDELINES BUDGET BY JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND ESTABLISH
A REGIONAL CLIMATE CLOUDED
PROGRAM TO ASSIST UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS STATEWIDE
PUBLIC IN OTHER GRANT MONIES --
SIMILAR CONCERNS --
RAISED BY STAFF --
YOU KNOW ALL ON WORKLOAD --
MOST NOTABLY THAT THAT THE FIRST
YEAR IS IS VERY MUCH ABOUT
ESTABLISHING GRANT --
GUIDELINES AND PROCESSES --
AND IN OUTLYING YEARS OR MORE
ABOUT ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE
GRANTS AND THERE IS DEFINITELY
UNCERTAINTY IN THOSE OUTLINED
YEARS -- ONE
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY GRANT APPLICATIONS ARE
MIGHT BE --
SO THAT THAT COULD BE AN ISSUE
WE HAVE BASS THESE THREE
POSITIONS ON OUR EXPERIENCE OF
OF DEVELOPING GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT APPEAR THROUGH THE STREETS
GROWTH COUNCIL --
AND FEEL THAT THOSE THOSE THREE
POSITIONS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE EXPERIENCE WE'VE HAD IN
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS IN
IMPLEMENTING.
A PROGRAMS --
CLEAN THE OUT YEARS.
THE FOCUS IS DEFINITELY IN A
SHIFT FROM DEVELOPMENT OF THE
GUIDELINES --
TO MORE OUR REACH TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE GUIDELINES --
AND AND YOU KNOW IT ADMINISTER
THE GRANTS IN THOSE OUT YEARS SO
THAT'S WHERE WE SEE THE KIND OF
THE NEED --
DEFINITELY SHIFTING IN AND MAYBE --
BUT WE THINK FOR NOW THAT THOSE
THREE POSITIONS OR WHAT WE NEED
TO TO AT LEAST GET THE GRANT
PROGRAM.
A GUIDE LINES UP AND RUNNING IN
AND GET [inaudible]
GRAHAM IMPLEMENTED.
OF HIS PLAN.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD NOTE IS
THAT OPR GIVEN THEIR AND MERRY
OUT OF RESPONSIBILITIES FROM ST
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSELOR FOR
DUTY IS CAROLINE TEARS.
PRECISION MEDICINE THERE ARE
JUST A LOT OF THEM --
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES AT THE
JUST MANY AND AND I THINK THAT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THERE
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE IS IS
FAIRLY SMALL.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO TAKE
ON SOME OF THESE DUTIES SO THIS
WAS WHAT WE THINK IS THE RIGHT
LEVEL OF RESOURCES BUT WERE
WILLING TO TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION THE SOUTH COMMENTS
AND JUST RETHINK THIS AND AND
COME BACK WITH MORE INFORMATION.
OKAY.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON SOME.
COMMENTS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
SO I MAYBE YOU CAN DIG IN JUST A
LITTLE BIT ON ON THE ISSUE OF
THE GUIDELINES WILL BE BY NEXT
YEAR.
RIGHT BY TWENTY TWENTY YES SO IT
AND THEN YES SIR --
SO I GUESS THE QUESTIONS ARE WHY
THEN ARE YOU PROPOSING.
UP UNTIL TWENTY EIGHT AND TWENTY
NINE THE THREE POSITIONS UNTIL
THEN.
AND WON'T THE GUIDELINES HAVE A
LOT TO DO WITH --
THE ACTUAL WORKLOAD.
YES OF THE IN SO THE AGAIN THAT
THE FIRST YEAR WE HAVE --
DEVELOP GREAT GUIDELINES AND BY
OCTOBER --
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THEN TO FELT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GUIDELINES
BY JULY --
TWENTY TWENTY WERE ALSO --
REQUIRED --
TO ADVANCE PAYMENT GUIDELINES
THERE'S NO DEADLINE ON THAT --
BUT WE HOPE TO INCLUDE THAT IS
AND AND COINCIDE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM --
AGAIN ON THE OUT YEARS --
THE WORKLOAD IS IS GONNA BE
CONSIDERABLY DIFFERENT IN THAT
IT'S GONNA BE MUCH MORE INVOLVED
IN IN.
STAKEHOLDER OUT REACH --
OUT WE TO THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES --
TO ONE MAKE THEM UNDERSTAND THAT
THE PROCESS IN THE GUIDELINES --
IN TO SET THEM UP TO BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR FOR THE VARIETY OF
GRANTS THAT THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE TIME LINE UP TO TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT.
THE SENSOR THAT WAS CREATED IN
IN THE ORIGINAL BILL. FOR THE
PROGRAM.
OKAY ANYMORE QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
NONE HEARING NONE THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR TIME --
ISSUE.
ELEVEN I GUESS UP BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
JUST.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
NIELSEN DANIEL BRANDON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH WAS ISSUED LAST
NIGHT. TO IMPLEMENT THE HOMELESS
AID FOR PLANNING AND SHELTER
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY.
THE FIRST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED THE CITIES.
AND THE FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE BASED ON SHARE OF THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HOMELESS
POPULATION POINT IN TIME COUNT.
WITH NO ALLOCATION EXCEEDING 30%
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT AVAILABLE.
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR PLANNING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS NAVIGATION
AND OTHER APPROVED USES.
APPLICATIONS AND JOINT --
SORRY TRAFFIC JOINT REGIONAL
PLANS WILL BE DUE TO THE AGENCY
BY DECEMBER FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN APPLICANTS
WILL HAVE UNTIL ABOUT FEBRUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TO ADOPT
THEIR FINAL JOINT REGIONAL PLAN.
REGIONAL PLANNING ALLOCATIONS
WILL BE DISPERSED BY MARCH FIRST --
TWENTY TWENTY IT TO BE TO INSURE
FUNDS ARE BEING EXPENDED QUICKLY
INTO JUST IMMEDIATELY
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM --
50% OF THE OF PLANNING
ALLOCATIONS MUST BE EXPENDED BY
MARCH FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AB WITH A 100%
OF THE REGIONAL PILING
ALLOCATIONS BEING COMMITTED --
BY THE YEAR AFTER THAT MARCH
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO HI I'M.
AND TH. 1100% OF THE MILESTONES
ALLOCATION MUST BE EXPENDED BY
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND A FINAL REPORT ON THE
EXPENDITURES MUST BE RUSS SENT
TO PCS H. BY SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THE TRAILER BILL OF PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT I LEFT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
DESPITE RECENT SIGNIFICNT
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE
SIGNIFICANT NEED STOCKTON.
A EXIST IN THIS AREA AT WELL
ABOVE 60% --
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
PROPORTION OF A SHELTERED
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD MAKE
HEADWAY IN ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE I'D MET DEMANDS.
SPECIFICALLY THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TOWARD.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE OTHER
COMPONENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR MILESTONES IS A RISKY
VENTURE IN OUR MIND IT'S
UNCERTAIN HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL RESPOND TO THAT AND SO WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
OTHER APPROACHES THAT WOULD HAVE.
MORE CERTAIN BENEFITS TOWARDS
THE HOMELESS POPULATION THANK
YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO RESPOND TO THEM.
WE AT LEE BELIEVE THAT TAKING
THIS APPROACH PROVIDES
INCENTIVES FOR LOCALS TO
ACTUALLY DEVELOP SHELTERS --
TO ASSIST THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
WE ARE PROVIDING THAT THIS
REPORT ON THE BACK AND TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO DO SO
[inaudible]
OKAY COLLEAGUES.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE APPRECIATE AND
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS --
WE ARE EAGER TO SEE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WE SUPPORT
MILESTONES FLEXIBILITY AND
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT REGIONS THAT
HAVE SPENT A LOT OF THEIR OWN
RESOURCES AND ON ALREADY
REDUCING THEIR HOMELESS
POPULATION AS SAN BERNADINO
HOUSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AUGMENTATION
INCREASE FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY
SERVICES FOR HOMELESSNESS.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
LAST YEAR'S AUGMENTATION --
THE THREE MILLION THIS YEAR WE
WE CERTAINLY AGREE WITH AND AND
ARE EAGER TO TO HELP THE
GOVERNOR --
DISBURSES FUNDS AND AND ADDRESS
THE THE CRISIS THAT WE ARE
FACING MANY OF OUR CITIES WE
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE REVIEW THE
TRAILER BILL FOR THE OTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
MILESTONES.
I'M WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT ON THE
IDEA OF INCENTIVES --
INCENTIVES ARE WEEDS WE SEE IS
THE BEST APPROACH TO TO GET
CITIES AND ANY BASICALLY ANYBODY
TO DO WHAT WE WANTED TO DO ALSO.
WITH AFFORD REVIEW IN THAT
TRAILER BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
QUESTION FOR YOU I'M WHERE A
STATEWIDE ACSI WORKING AS ASIAN
REPRESENTING RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH PROVIDERS.
AND HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO REALLY
REVIEW THAT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS IT WAS LAST NIGHT.
AND I WOULD ADVOCATE THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'VE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE --
A BIG CONSIDERATION IN TERMS OF
NEED I'M CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF YOU
BETTER AND SHELTERED.
I'M OVER 80% AND MUST OVERSEE
YOUR SEATS HAVE REALLY HIGH
NUMBERS OF AND SHELTERED YOU.
I'M EVEN IF THEY ARE ONLY 11% OF
THE OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION
WE KNOW THAT THEY WILL EXIT INTO
BEING A CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
ADULT IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THEM WHEN THEY'RE HERE.
SO I'M JUST LOOKING AT WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
AROUND THE HOMELESS YOUTH
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT IS
POTENTIALLY A WHAT A MODEL MAY
BE FOR ADDRESSING YOUTH NEEDS IN
TERMS OF PLANNING AND SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS FOR HOW DO WE
ADDRESS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR YOU?
AND SIR IS ONE THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WEIGH IN ON THE GOOD
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND YOUR
OFFICES AROUND HOW WE CAN DO
THAT BETTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M FAIRLY TAKE TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
REPRESENT ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE STILL NEEDS TO
BE SOME OF THE SAUSAGE MAKING
THAT WE TALK ABOUT IN THESE
COMMITTEES ON HOW THIS FUNDING
IS -- COMES
DOWN TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO FUND HELPING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMBAT HOMELESSNESS
WE WOULD SAY THAT LAST YEAR'S
HEAT MODEL WE'RE STILL HAVING
SOME LESSONS LEARNED THAT MONEY
IS JUST NOW GOING OUT IN CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE --
FIGURING OUT HOW TO BEST USE
THAT MONEY WE THINK WITH
COUNTIES BECAUSE WE OFFER THE
FULL CONTINUUM OF SERVICES NOT
JUST PUBLIC SAFETY AND MAYBE
CODE ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO THE
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS --
EVEN ANIMAL SERVICES PROGRAM I
MEANT TO HELP COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS SO WILL BE ASKING
FOR SOME OF THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TO COME DIRECTLY TO
COUNTIES --
BUT ALSO STRONGLY STRONGLY
STRONGLY VALUE COLLABORATION --
BECAUSE NO CITY OR NO COUNTY CAN
DO THIS BY THEMSELVES SO AGAIN
WE WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS PROPOSAL WITH STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
FOURTEEN LARGEST HI COUNTIES IN
THE STATE.
I HOMELESSNESS AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IS ONE OF THE URBAN
CHINESE TOP PRIORITIES WE'RE
CERTAINLY VERY SUPPORTIVE --
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES COMING
LOCAL LEAD TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND CERTAINLY ARE
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU THROUGH THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVERYONE --
YES -- IT
COULD YOU EXPLAIN MORE OF WHAT
THE GENERAL PURPOSE INCENTIVE
FUNDS.
I MEAN.
AND WHAT'S.
REALLY HOW HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT'S GOING TO WORK.
AND HOW OLD HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU SEE THE LOCALS QUALIFYING
FOR THEM.
SO IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE
REWARDS FINDING --
THAT WILL BE.
DESIGNED TO THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WHERE THE AGENCY WILL
WORK WITH THE CONTINUES OF CARE
AND THAT THE LARGE CITIES.
I AM TO OUTLINE OF MILESTONES
THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE ACHIEVABLE
WITHIN THEIR OWN PLANS AND THEN
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL BE MEASURED
AGAINST.
THEIR OWN --
TARGETS AND OF COURSE AGENCY
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE TARGETS A REASONABLE --
WITH REGARD TO THE INCENTIVE
DOLLARS PURPOSE DOLLARS THAT GO
OUT IF THESE TARGETS ARE MET
WELL WE ENVISION AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THEY ARE USED TO
CONTINUE OUR FURTHER HOUSING
GOALS.
WITHIN THOSE JURISDICTIONS ARE
WITHIN THOSE --
CEO SEES THEY ARE GENERAL
PURPOSE AND THAT WOULD BE LEFT
UP TO THE CO SEASON THE
JURISDICTIONS WITH.
SO HOW HOW DOES NOT DIRECTLY
HELP WITH HOMELESSNESS I MEAN
THE USER.
DOLLARS THAT --
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL ANXIOUS.
TO DO IT DIRECTLY WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO HELP OUR HOMELESS SO
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT HOW HOW DOES
A GENERAL PURPOSE INCENTIVE FUND.
DIRECTLY HELP WITH THE ISSUE OF
OUR HOMELESSNESS WE BELIEVE THAT
BUT BY CREATING THE SHELTERS AND
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES
IS GOING TO CREATE COSTS.
ON THE JURISDICTIONS AND WE
LEAVE THESE FUNDS THESE
INCENTIVE FUNDS WILL HELP THAT.
BUT WE DO WANT TO JURISDICTIONS
TO CHOOSE THEIR PATH FORWARD
WITH THE PLANNING DOLLARS AND
THEREFORE CHOOSE OUR PATH
FORWARD WITH THE REWARD FUNDS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
NO MORE QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GIVE
SHADE IT [inaudible]
PLEASE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE A
TWELVE SHORT TERM PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION GRANTS --
MAKING A FRIEND [inaudible]
MORNING.
I LIKE MY DEPARTMENT PLEASE.
WITH SOME QUESTIONS.
I'VE DANIELLE BRANDON AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND IN TRAILER BILL LNGUAGE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION GRANTS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AND WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. FOR THE
SHORT TERM GOALS H. CD WILL
ESTABLISH THESE NEW TO SHORT
TERM STATEWIDE HOUSING GOALS.
FOR JURISDICTIONS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THESE TARGETS WILL BE BASED ON
THREE YEARS OF REINA XCELERATED
INTO TWO YEARS. EIGHT CITY WILL
ALLOCATE THE INCREASE TARGETS TO
JURISDICTIONS ACCORDING TO
SPECIFIED FACTORS INCLUDING
SHARE OF JOBS AVAILABLE.
THE FIRST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
JURISDICTIONS AND WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED BY DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH THE
JURISDICTIONS COMMITMENT TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE REGION.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A REGIONAL
ACTION PLAN.
THE SECOND HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WILL GO TO REGION'S WITH
UP 250% OF THE FUNDS BEING
DISPERSED BY DECEMBER. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO PROVIDE UP
FRONT FUNDING. TO CONDUCT
REGIONAL --
PLANNING ACTIVITIES AND CONVENE
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN THE REGION.
THERE ARE MANY 50% WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED BY DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY OFFENSIVE MIDDLE AND
APPROVAL OF A REGIONAL ACTION
PLAN.
REGIONAL ACTION PLANS WILL
IDENTIFY PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
BARRIERS TO PRODUCTION.
AND OTHER ACTIVITIES NECESSARY
TO INCREASE PRODUCTION.
THE PLAN WILL ALSO IDENTIFY THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WILL BE USED TO
DETERMINE PRODUCTION REWARD
AMOUNTS FOR JURISDICTIONS.
IF A JURISDICTION IS IN A REGION
OR COUNTY THAT IS NOT SUBMITTED
A PLAN THE KIDS WITH THEIR OWN
PLAN FOR EACH CD APPROVAL. EIGHT
CITY WILL IDENTIFY METHODOLOGY
METHODOLOGY TO DISTRIBUTE
INCENTIVE AWARDS TO THESE
JURISDICTIONS.
FINALLY THE REGIONAL PLAN IS THE
MOST CRITICAL COMPONENT.
OF THIS WE WANT TO INCENT LOCALS
AND REGIONS TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MEET THE INCREASED PRODUCTION
AND INDICATE HOW THEY INTEND TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS.
REGION'S WILL DETERMINE THE
METHODOLOGY TO AGREED UPON
ACTIVITIES.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S A
PROPOSED ON THE SERVER IT
INCLUDES SEVERAL PIECES SOME
THAT ARE AIMED AT INCREASING
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE SHORT
TERM AND SOME.
AND INCREASING --
PRODUCTION IN THE LONG TERM AS
FAR AS THE SHORT TERM COMPONENTS.
WE HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH
THESE PROPOSALS --
THE FIRST IS THAT THE STRATEGY
THAT'S PROPOSED AN ESTABLISHING
THE SHORT TERM GOALS A SEEMS TO
BE A CONTINUATION OF THE STATE'S
EXISTING STRATEGY THAT IT'S HAD.
FOR A SEVERAL YEARS THROUGH THE
HOUSING ELEMENT AND REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION ARENA
PROCESS.
IN OTHER IT'S NOT CLEAR THIS
PROPOSAL KIND OF DIFFERENTIATES
ITSELF FROM THAT PASSED STRATEGY
THAT --
RESEARCH BY OUR OFFICE AND
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS HAS FOUND
HAS BEEN GENERALLY INEFFECTIVE
IN ACHIEVING ITS GOALS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT INSTEAD OF FOCUSING
ON THESE SHORT TERM CHANGES A WE
WE GREW THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
THAT THAT FOCUSING ON WAYS TO
FURTHER IMPROVE THE EXISTING
LONG TERM PLANNING STRUCTURE.
A WOULD BE A BETTER USE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORT IN THIS
AREA OUR OTHER CONCERN IS WITH
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND
FUNDING SET ASIDE FOR A KIND OF
INCENTIVE FUNDS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
OF THE STATE HAS A TRIED SIMILAR
APPROACHES IN THE PAST OF MAKING
POTS OF FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO ENCOURAGE THEM --
TO APPROVE A PLAN FOR TO PROVE
HOW REVIEW OF THIS PAST PROGRAMS --
DOESN'T --
DOESN'T SUGGEST THAT THEY HAD A
A SIGNIFICANT MEASURABLE IMPACT
ON THOSE LOCAL APPROVALS OF
HOUSING BECAUSE OF THIS.
WE THINK THAT THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION COULD ESSENTIALLY BE A
PRETTY RISKY BET FROM THE
LEGISLATURE'S PERSPECTIVE --
YOU KNOW AN ALTERNATIVE USE OF
THIS FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE --
ALLOCATING THE FUNDING DIRECTLY
FOR SUBSIDIES FOR CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WOULD
YIELD A MORE CERTAIN BENEFIT
MAYBE SOMETHING LIKE FIVE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL FOR DOUBLE
UNITS ACROSS THE STATE --
WALL WERE SKEPTICAL OF THE KIND
OF THE SHORT TERM APPROACHES
PRESENTED BY THE THE GOVERNOR WE
DO AGREE.
THAT IT WOULD BE WORTHWHILE.
TO CONTINUE TO RETHINK THE LONG
TERM PLANNING PROCESS SEES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN SEVERAL
IMPORTANT STEPS IN THIS AREA IN
RECENT YEARS.
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THERE
CONTINUE TO BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENT --
AND WE DID ISSUE A REPORT ABOUT
A MONTH AGO WERE WE OUTLINED A
SEVERAL SUGGESTIONS THAT WE
THINK WE TAKE IN THE
CONSIDERATION OF FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS FOR REFORMS. TO
THOSE PLANNING PROCESSES AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO GO INTO THOSE IF THE
KID SUBCOMMITTEE.
WOULD BE INTERESTED ONE TO SPEAK
TO ONE PARTICULAR ELEMENT OF THE
THE GOVERNOR'S LONG TERM CHANGES.
ARE THE MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED --
TYING.
SB ONE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
OF FUNDING TO A PROGRESS TOWARDS.
MEETING THESE KIND OF LONG TERM.
PLANNING GOALS --
IN WALL --
WELL WE AGREE THAT THIS IS A THE
STATE DISCRETIONARY POT THAT THE
STATE ALLOCATES AT THE CITIES.
AND IN THAT RESPECT IT IT IT
DOES PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF IF WE
ARE INTERESTED IN SHIFTING THE
INCENTIVES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN
THE AREA.
OF HOUSING BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THIS APPROACH COULD PRESENT
SEVERAL DRAWBACKS.
THE FIRST IS THAT --
TYING.
TYING THE SB ONE ALLOCATIONS TO
A PROGRESS IN THE RENO PROCESS.
SENSUALLY COULD BE ESSENTIALLY
HOLDING CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FACTORS THAT IN
SOME CASES ARE BEYOND THEIR
CONTROL --
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE IF
THE SP ONE FUNDS ARE TIED TO
MEETING PARTICULAR PRODUCTION --
TARGETS --
NO IN LOOKING AT THE DETAILS OF
THE THE TRAILER BILL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED IN
THIS AREA IT APPEARS THAT THEY
ARE ATTEMPTING TO TRY TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THAT ISSUE.
BY TYING THE SB ONE FUNDING MORE
TO PROGRESS TOWARDS UP KIND OF
PLANE ANGLES HAVING TO COMPLY
HOUSING ELEMENT IN MAKING ZONING
CHANGES BUT IT APPEARS AT LEAST --
IN THE TRAILER BILL HERE --
THAT THEY ARE KIND OF STOPPING
SHORT AT LEAST NOW OF TYING IT
DIRECTLY TO MEETING CERTAIN
PRODUCTION GOALS SO THAT THE THE
MINISTRATION MAYBE TAKEN SOME
STEPS TO MITIGATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THERE.
ANOTHER ISSUE THOUGH IS THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS PART OF FUNDING
OBVIOUSLY WAS SET FORTH BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS TO MEET ONE PURPOSE WHICH
IS THE MAINTENANCE OF LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS --
AND THAT BY TYING IT.
YEAH THAT MAY IN NO IN GENERAL.
INCREASING THE APPROVAL OF
HOUSING ACROSS THE STATE MAY BE
WORTHWHILE BUT ATTEMPTING TO DO
BOTH OF THESE GOALS WITH ONE
PART OF FUNDING KIND OF REDUCES
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO ACHIEVE
BOTH OF THOSE GOALS [inaudible]
YES.
ANALYSTS IS BROUGHT UP A POINT
IT WAS IT IS MY INTENT TO SPEAK
A LOT ABOUT.
AS WE PROCEED TO THE BUDGET.
THE IDEA OF PUNITIVE ACTION.
WITH SB ONE FUNDS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
IS A SERIOUS SERIOUS BREACH OF
PROMISE AND FAITH. TO THE VOTERS.
WE WERE TOLD [inaudible]
IN.
AND SB ONE AND THEN THEY
REJECTED THE REFERENDUM.
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO BE GOING
TO YOU.
AND NOW TO THREATEN TO WITHDRAW
THAT.
IF THEY DON'T MEET HOUSING GOALS
AND I'M GONNA TALK A LOT MORE
ABOUT THAT AS WE PROCEED.
THAT'S UNCONSCIONABLE
[inaudible]
AND IF THIS IS TO HAPPEN.
IT OUGHT NOT HAPPEN SIMPLY IN A
TRAILER BILL.
TRAILER BILLS HAVE BECOME A VERY
CORRUPT WAY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET.
AND MY FEAR.
AND THAT'S WHY BRING IT UP EVERY
CHANCE I GET.
THAT IDEAS LIKE THIS TEND TO
JUST SLIP IN.
THE TRAILER BILLS.
THE LEGISLATURE NOW IS DOING
MAJOR POLICY EVERY YEAR
SUBSTANTIAL.
AND TRAILER BILLS.
AND EVERY YEAR WE ENTERTAIN MORE
TRAILER BILLS I THINK WE'RE UP
TO SEVENTY ONE POSSIBLE THIS
YEAR.
IT WON'T END UP BEING THAT MANY
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
AND THEN IN THE FORTIES.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN OCCASIONS.
SEVERAL.
WHERE I'M SITTING ON A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE BUDGET?
AND THAT'S THE ONLY COMMITTEE
WERE THIS MAJOR POLICY ISSUES
GOING TO BE DISCUSSED.
NOW THE ONE THAT.
ANALYSTS SUGGEST WILL BE
DISCUSSED A LOT OF OTHER PLACES
I SURE YOU.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT WE HAVE
TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS.
ABOUT PROCESS. TO ENSURE THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND THE DAYS THE LOOSE
WAY THAT WE USE TRAILER BILLS IS
CERTAINLY PROBLEMATIC BUT
GETTING BACK TO THIS POINT.
I THINK WE DID A VERY GOOD TREAD
VERY SOFTLY.
ON ANY PUNITIVE ACTION.
TOWARDS AREAS THAT DON'T MEET
THEIR HOUSING REQUIREMENTS.
IN ANOTHER ITEM I'M GOING TO
EMPHASIZE A POINT THAT WILL
RELATE TO THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR A LET
ME [inaudible] TO THAT.
THANKS OF A FOLLOW ON THE CENTER
NIELSEN QUESTION SO TELL ME HOW
EXPLAINED TO VOTERS.
THAT VOTED FOR SB.
ONE THE NEXUS BETWEEN HOUSING IN
AND WHAT THEY VOTED FOR AND SB.
ONE SO WE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
VERY STRONG NEXUS BETWEEN
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
OBVIOUSLY NEED THE ROADS TO GET
TO YOUR HOUSE AND TO YOUR WORK --
BUT I DO WANT TO KNOW THAT TO
THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS THAT WE
HAVE WRITTEN IN A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO UNDERGO AN TO REVIEW
THE TYPES OF FUNDS THAT WILL BE
ELIGIBLE.
WE'VE SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED
THAT THIS PARTICULAR FUND
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
THE REQUIRE.
FACE CAN NOT HAVE THOSE FUNDS
WITH HELD OUR ACTUAL
REQUIREMENTS NOW THEIR CURRENT
LAW THAT JURISDICTION'S ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH ITS NOT
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS AND IT'S
NOT PRODUCTION.
GOALS AT THIS TIME SO SANTA THE
CONCERNED HOW YOU DO EXPLAINED I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE INVOLVED STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCALS TO BE
IN COMPLIANCE BEFORE THOSE FUNDS
ARE WITHOUT.
OKAY SO WHEN THE VOERS SAYS
LOOK AT I THOUGHT SB ONE WAS
ABOUT ROAD IMPROVEMENTS.
AND I SEE THAT THE STATE IS
USING IT FOR LEISURE ALL
IMPORTANT I MEAN HOUSING IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
BOB USING FOR HOUSING
[inaudible]
AGAIN HOW.
TELL ME I I GOT THE WHOLE
STAKEHOLDER THING AND OTHERS ARE
GOING.
TO TALK ABOUT IT BUT YOU KNOW.
TO THE VOTER IN GARDEN GROVE WHO
VOTED FOR SB ONE BECAUSE FOLKS
TOLD THAT PERSON THAT IT WAS
GONNA BE USED TO ROADS. EIGHT I
NEED THE THIRTY SECOND
EXPLANATION AS TO WHAT THAT.
NECKLACES ACKLES THAT DEBBIE DR
HOUSING POLICY THE CIA JUST
WANNA QUICK TOP LINE THIS IS TWO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE'S RIGHT THE
SHORT TERM SELECT OPTION AND
THIS LONGER TERM SO THAT
EVERYTHING WOULD THAT WOULD BE
DISCUSSED MEDICAL POSSIBLE COME
BACK TO YOU OFFER
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ORDER TO
ADOPT RIGHT.
SO THERE'S A BLANK THE PROCESS
BY WHICH ANY CONCERN VOTER COULD
RAISE OR YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS AND TO
BE ABLE.
ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER
THAT MADE SENSE IN TERMS OF
TRYING OTHER.
YOU KNOW COMPLY TO OTHER STATE
HOUSING LAWS TO CERTAIN FUNDING
SOURCE SO I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT TO MAKE IN A
MULTI YEAR DISCUSSION PROCESS
NOTHING'S HAPPENING NOW IN THIS
TRAILER BILL TO ENACT THAT.
SO. TO THAT POINT RIGHT THERE
ARE --
COMPLIANCE WITH HAVING ABOUT
HOUSING ELEMENT FOR LOTS OF
HOUSING RESOURCES AND EVEN FOR
ALREADY FOR SB ONE PLANNING
GRANTS.
THAT'S A THRESHOLD REQUIREMENT
SO THIS IS A WHAT DOES SEEM YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS BEEN AROUND IN OH
WOW THIS ONE IS GONNA TAKE ME
THERE ACTUALLY IS A PRECEDENT
FOR US TO SAY HEY YOU NEED TO BE
COMPLIANT WITH CERTAIN ASPECTS
OF HOUSING LAW.
TRANSPORTATION LAW THAT EXISTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE INTERCONNECTED
IN THE PLANNING PROCESS RIGHT SO
IF YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOUNG COMING YOUR NOSE AT LIKE
THE HOUSING CORRECTION PROCESS
BUT YOU WANT THOSE
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS OR VICE
VERSA RIGHT --
THAT COULD BE A ROBE A PART OF
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION CYCLIC
PROCESS BUT I THINK THE ANSWER
IS NOTHING IS BEING DONE RIGHT
NOW WE WANT TO DISCUSS THOSE IN
A REAL HOLISTIC AND TRANSPARENT
WAY.
IN A LONG TERM PROCESS NO I I
THINK THE DISCUSSION OF GET VERY
ROBUST.
SO.
BUT I GUESS WE'RE NOT TRYING.
TO SNEAK THAT IN HERE I TRAILER
BILL THERE'S A LINK TO THE SOUL
AND WHAT I'M SORRY GO AHEAD IF I
MANAGING FOR THE PROVISION Là
AND IN THE BILL ITSELF AND I CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AFTER THIS.
BUT IT'S ALSO MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THOSE FUNDS WOULD NOT BE
TAKEN AND THEN USE ON HOUSING
THEY WOULD BE TAKING AND THEN
REINVESTED IN --
TRANSPORTATION --
YEAH REDISTRIBUTION OF THE STATE
FOR OTHER LOCAL CAR WELL LET ME
TELL YOU THAT THE THE FELLOW OR
MY ALLEN GARDEN GROVE WHEN WE
SAY -- IT'S
BEING I KNOW YOU'RE PAYING IT'S
BEING RE DISTRIBUTED SOMEWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE THE CITY'S NOT IN
COMPLIANCE THAT'S BUT WE'LL
LEAVE THAT FOR NOW.
SO THE NEXT IS WITH RESPECT.
TO OTHER LEVERS USED --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT IS COMPLIED WITH --
GOVERNOR SUIT HUNTINGTON BEACH
AND THE AYE.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN PEAKING TOO
EARLY SO AS I SIT HERE I GOT A
LETTER FROM THE GOVERNOR SAYING
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS
GONNA GAUGE IN CONVERSATION WITH
CITY HUNDRED BEACH GREAT.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK LAWSUITS
ARE THE WAY TO MOST EFFECTIVELY
RESERVE. TO BE RESOLVED.
OF THIS CONTROVERSY SO I'M I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THAT.
WHAT OTHER CITIES ARE SORT OF IN
THE SIGHTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN TERMS OF FILING SUIT?
OF IN TO TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
[inaudible]
SPEC [inaudible]
IN POPULATION.
WHO IF SANCTIONED WOULD HAVE
ALMOST ZERO IMPACT IT WAS COOL
KIND OF THE DELICIOUS IRONY OF
IN SINGLING OUT FREQUENT?
HUNTINGTON BEACH I DON'T LIKE IT
EITHER.
BUT WE DON'T MY GOODNESS.
WELL I WILL SEE THIS IS WE LIVE
IN IN YOUR SIGHTS.
I WOULD BE TO ANY ANY PENDING
LITIGATION I WILL CONNECTED BACK
TO THIS RIGHT THE THE PLANNING
GRANTS BEING PROPOSED ARE NOT
TIED TO BEING HAVING HOW ABOUT
HOUSING ELEMENT IN THE PLANT IN
FACT THEY CAN BE USED TO GET
INTO COMPLIANCE SO THERE'S A
REAL LONG.
YOU KNOW RUN AWAY RIGHT TO MAKE
SURE IF WE CAN HELP ANY
JURISDICTION GET COMPLIANCE
ALREADY.
WITHIN THE FIRST COUPLE MONTHS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S TERM WE HAVE
ENGAGED IN A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
WITH THOSE RESTRICTIONS WERE
VERY PRO ACTIVELY TRYING TO HELP
THEM GET INTO COMPLIANCE.
ONE THAT WAS ON THE INITIAL LIST
OF FORTY SEVEN NOT QUITE
RESTRICTIONS THAT EXISTED THE
STAR THE GOVERNOR'S TERM OTHERS
WILL.
I WE'VE BEEN RUNNING QUITE A BIT
TACKLE SYSTEMS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IS TO FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO HELP YOU KNOW
IT'S PROVIDED AND THEY THESE
PLANNING GRANTS ARE.
YOU PUTTING THAT FORTHRIGHT HEY
WHATEVER YOU NEED TO GET TO THE
TO TO WHATEVER IT TO BE MORE
HOUSING FRIENDLY HAVE A POLICIES
THAT.
PRIMER DEVELOPED DEVELOPER
CERTAINTY TO REDUCE REGULATORY
BURDEN LET'S TAKE CARE OF THOSE
SO THAT WHEN THE MARKET EXISTS
FOR HOUSING IN YOUR JURISDICTION
YOU ARE READY TO GO AND OPEN FOR
BUSINESS. TO DO HOUSING SO
THERE'S QUITE A BIT AND THAT IS
THE NEW PART OF THIS PROCESS I
WOULD NOTE THESE PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE A
PART OF THE INCENTIVE PAYMENTS.
ARE VERY SIGNIFICAN IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE FUNDED AT
THE STATE LEVEL BEFORE IN TERMS
OF ACTUAL PLENTY DOLLARS --
TO DEAL WITH MAYBE SECRET
STREAMLINING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SPECIFIC PLANNING --
POSTED FEE THE SCHEDULES
PROVIDING THOSE THINGS THAT
DEVELOPERS NEED SO THAT THAT
COMMITTEES MAYBE THAT.
YOU KNOW DIDN'T MAKE SENSE
DIDN'T PENCIL OUT TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR NOW NOW DO RIGHT
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT THAT IS
ABOUT FOR SAY OKAY THAT IS A
RIGHT PLACE TO GO TO GO DEVELOP
WILL THERE BE MORE CREATIVE AND
AND FOR THE LEVEL SO.
THAT IS THE THESIS BEHIND THE
THE FRONT LOADING OF THE
PLANNING GRANT AT BOTH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION IN THE RETAIL LEVEL
IS TO GET READY SO THAT THIS
KIND OF SHORT TERM CATALYTIC.
INCREASE PRODUCTION PROGRAM CAN
CAN HELP BUT ALSO LONG TERM
RIGHT IF YOU PUT THOSE POLICIES
IN PLACE.
KLAY RIGHT YOU'RE MORE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS YOU READY TO DEVELOP
MORE ON A LONG TERM BASIS AND SO.
I DID WANT THAT TO TO GO WITHOUT
MENTIONING.
SO THOSE ALL THOSE RESOURCES IN
ADDITION TO ALL THE STUFF FOR OF
COURSE ALREADY DOING WITH WITH
WITH JURISDICTIONS.
WHEATLAND --
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO IN
SITTING DOWN WITH THANK YOU CAN
VIEW YOUR CAN GET YOU CAN GET
COMPLAINT WE DOING THAT WITH A
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS AND LIKE
I SAID WE HAVE.
ALREADY GOTTEN SOME BACK IN THE
COMPLIANCE CERTAINLY --
IT A LOT OF FIRE ANDERSON
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAD BEEN NON
RESPONSIVE --
THAT'S THAT'S WITHOUT QUESTION --
BUT WE EVEN HAVE A NUMBER OF OF
HOUSING UNLESS IN FOR OF YOU SO
WE'RE HOPE WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT
THAT NUMBER WOULD YOU
SIGNIFICANTLY.
JUST JUST AS A MOTHER ANOTHER
POINT I MADE MY LIVING AS A
LITIGATOR --
AND SO.
THERE'S A TIME AND PLACE --
I AM CONCERNED THAT LOTS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY MAY BE WASTED.
I SUPPOSE NOT WASTE IF YOU'RE
THE ACTUAL LITIGATOR BUT BUT
WASTED -- IN
LITIGATION SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
AGAIN WE WE CAN COME TO A
RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT RESORTING LITIGATION --
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I HOPE WE CAN
DO I'LL CONCLUDE BY COMMENDING
THE GOVERNOR FOR AGREEING.
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND AND PERHAPS
WE CAN AVOID.
WASTING TAXPAYER MONEY.
BUT YEAH I MEAN YOU HAVE IT
MAYBE ADD IN THE YOU KNOW YOU
PRIVACY IN THE GOVERNOR WHAT
CAME UP THERE AND SOME THAT WE
ARE CERTAINLY ARE AWARE OF IT
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE --
EVEN OUTSTANDING STATE ACTION
JURISDICTIONS ARE DON'T HAVE
COMPLIANCE ON HOUSING ARE
SUBJECT TO OTHER THIRD PARTY
ACTION THAT IS ACTUALLY QUITE
MORE PERVASIVE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL OF THIRD PARTIES SINGLE
CITY SO.
THERE IS A VULNERABILITY THERE
OF BEING ON COMPLAIN THAT OFTEN
REARS ITS HEAD THROUGH
LITIGATION BUT NOT FROM THE
STATE EVEN BEFORE LOCAL LOCAL.
THANK YOU MANAGER --
YES.
I WAS GOING TO BRING THIS UP IN
A SUBSEQUENT ITEM BUT I MAY WILL
BRING IT UP NOW BECAUSE IT'S
ENTIRELY RELEVANT HERE.
AND UNDERSTAND THIS PHENOMENA
DID NOT OCCUR.
ON YOUR WATCH YEAR WITH THE DID
YOU TO MEMBERS BEING PRESENT
[inaudible]
NOR --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME [inaudible]
PREVIOUS BUDGET.
BUT WE HAVE HAD COUNTY.
VERY WEALTHY COUNTIES COME IN
AND ASK FOR LONG TERM EXEMPTIONS.
EIGHT YEARS.
FROM THEIR HIDING REQUIREMENTS.
THEN SUCCEEDED IN GETTING IT IN
THE BUDGET.
AND NOT HAVE TO COMPLY.
AND I THINK THAT IS THE ULTIMATE
IN HYPOCRISY.
IN SAN.
MARCOS IN THE PAST.
AND BECAME LAW THERE'S A PART OF
THE BUDGET.
THAT SHOULD BE UNDONE.
THEN THEY SHOULD NOT.
HAVE THAT LONG TERM EXEMPTION.
EXACT THE ITEM OF INEQUITY
UNFAIRNESS.
AND DESTROYS VASE IN GOVERNMENT.
AND IT TO ME THE HYPOCRISY OF A
VERY WEALTHY COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT SELL WHAT WE NEED EIGHT
YEARS TO DO THIS.
BUT HUNTINGTON BEACH WE WENT NO
NO.
WE'RE GONNA HURT YOU.
THAT IS NOT THE WAY WE SHOULD DO
POLICY EFFECT POLICY AND CAL --
JUST ONE ONE MORE ITEM FOR ME
THAT -- WE
TALKED ABOUT IN THE EARLIER
ISSUE IS AGAIN HOW MUCH OF THIS
FUNDING IS NOT TARGETED AT
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
OR HOMELESSNESS AND THE USE OF
SO MUCH MONEY --
FOR GENERAL PURPOSES.
I MEAN.
WE HAVE A REAL CRISIS AND I
UNDERSTAND AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
EVERYTHING THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
YOU AND OTHERS ARE DOING TO COME
UP WITH.
THE BEST IDEAS BUT THE ACTION OF
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS I MEAN
THOSE ARE VERY THOSE ARE
EMERGENCY ISSUES --
AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE KEEP PUTTING SO MUCH.
OF WHAT CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
USE FOR GENERAL PURPOSES.
I THINK YOU'RE SPEAKING TO THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS THE PART OF
THAT OF THIS PROPOSAL --
I WOULD I WOULD FIRST SAY THAT
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY I THINK THE
GOVERNOR PERSPECTIVE A
COMPLIMENTARY PROPOSAL ALL THE
OTHER FUNDING WE HAVE OUT THERE
FOR PRODUCTION --
FROM LAST YEAR'S HOUSING BONE
THAT'S PASSED FROM A PERMANENT
SOURCE FROM SB --
TO ON DOWN THE LINES EVEN SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS --
THE IS THAT THE BUDGET HAS
INCLUDED --
TO SPEAK TO THE GENERAL PURPOSE
IS PART OF THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS I WILL SAY --
HAVING WE HAVE WORKED IN THE
CITY ON A NUMBER OF INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE PAST AND WE HAVE
HEARD A LOT OF ANECDOTAL --
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY
BEING ABLE TO GET PROJECTS
THROUGH AN APPROVED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BECAUSE THEY HAD THE COVER
OF SAYING HEY IF YOU APPROVE
THIS PROJECT WE'RE GOING TO GET
MONEY FOR PARKS FOR EXAMPLE OR
GONNA GET MONEY FOR THIS KIND OF
PURPOSE THAT IS THE THESIS.
BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL THAT IT
SWEETENS --
SO TO SPEAK THE INCENTIVE TO
PRINT TO APPROVE HOUSING WHICH
WE KNOW SOMETIMES CAN HAVE A
TOUGH ROAD OF GETTING THROUGH
THE LOCAL PROCESS AND SO.
THERE ARE --
A LOT OF INSTANCES --
THAT WE ALL OFTEN HEAR ABOUT OF
THAT BEING A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL --
TO A DEVELOPER TO TO A CITY --
INTEREST MAYBE RECALCITRANT
THERE CATHERINE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE KIND OF SURPRISED ME
NOT WANT TO FOR HOUSING IS A
OKAY WILL I I'M GOING TO PROVE
THIS BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO GET THESE RESOURCES
THAT WE CAN USE. TO FUND OUR
OTHER NEED WITH THE PARKS OR A
PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS ARE OR WHAT
HAVE YOU SO THAT IS THE IDEA
BEHIND THAT THAT THAT PROPOSALS
IT.
IS AN INCENTIVE --
NOTHING'S BEING PUNITIVE IN THIS
WAY BUT IF IF IF CITIES ARE ABLE
TO MEET HIGHER GOALS OF THE
ARGUMENT PURSUE THESE THINGS
THAT MAKE HOUSING EASIER TO
BUILD --
MAKE IT MORE ATTRACTIVE
DEVELOPERS COMMITTEE COMMUNITY
AND THEN THE REWARDED BY YOU
KNOW SOME PAYMENT FOR GENERAL
PURPOSES CERTAINLY IT'S INCHING
POLICY BUT I'M SAYING THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE THESIS BOND THAT ARE.
ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE QUESTION
SENATORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
OF IF WE DO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'M SORRY REPUBLICAN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN.
ORGANIZATION OF BUSINESS AND
LABOR INTEREST THAT HAVE --
ORGANIZED AROUND ADVOCATING FOR
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS
IMPROVING THE X. AND QUALITY OF
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANNA START BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT HOUSING CRISIS THAT EXISTS
IN THE STATE AND THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THAT A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS HAS ON THE
ABILITY TO LIVE AND THRIVE IN
THE STATE ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE COMMEND THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS CALLING SUCH SIGNIFICANT
ATTENTION TO THE CRISIS IN HIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THROUGH ADD THE ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND MONEY INVESTMENTS AS WELL
AS SOME OF THE OTHER POLICY
PROPOSALS THAT HE IS --
PUTTING FORTH BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CAN AT THAT BEING
SAID MY ASSOCIATION IS VERY
CONCERNED.
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF TYING
HOUSING PRODUCTION OR PLANNING
GOALS TO SB ONE OR ANY OTHER
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IN THE
STATE -- AS
BOTH THE LA --
NOTED AND A CENTER NEAREST
NIELSEN NOTED WE THINK THIS RUNS
IN THE FACE OF PROMISES THAT
WERE NOT ONLY MADE.
TO AT THE VOTERS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN WITH --
THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
NINE IN THE DEFEAT OF
PROPOSITION SIX BUT MANY TIMES
BEFORE THAT PROPOSITION FORTY
TWO PROPOSITION.
TWENTY TWO VOTERS ARE WILLING
THEY HAVE SHOWN THEMSELVES TO BE
WILLING TO PAY MORE AT THE PUMP
AS LONG AS THAT MONEY IS
GUARANTEED AND SPENT ON
TRANSPORTATION.
AND SPENT ON TRANSPORTATION IN
EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY FOR EVERY
SINGLE MOTORIST IS PAYING AT THE
PUMP AND AT THE REGISTRATION FEE
EVERYONE IS DESERVING OF A
QUALITY TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
THE STATE --
SECONDARILY THOUGH I DON'T WANT
THE COMMITTEE TO FORGET THAT SB
ONE WAS NEGOTIATED AND CRAFTED
AFTER MANY YEARS OF CAREFUL
NEGOTIATION AND DIALOGUE.
TO ADDRESS ANOTHER CRISIS AND
THAT WAS A TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING CRISIS.
THE STATE AND LOCALS WERE FACING
A COMBINED ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR TEN YEAR
FUNDING SHORTFALL FOR JUST THE
MAINTENANCE.
AND SAFETY OF OUR EXISTING
SYSTEM.
SO BY POTENTIALLY TAKING AS WE
WILL BE IN PETER --
TO AGING BRIDGE HOLES PLEASE
STREETS AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE DIRECTLY
IMPACTING IN A NEGATIVE WAY THE
MOBILITY AND SAFETY OF THE
TRAVELING PUBLIC.
AT SO THANK YOU FOR THE HEALTHY
DIALOGUE THIS MORNING AND WE
LOOK FORWARD --
TO CONTINUED CONVERSATION THANKS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORTY MANAGER MEMBERS JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY A AGREED DEAL
DONE PACK IN THIS TRAILER BILL
AND YOU KNOW IN THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS AT THE GOVERNOR'S
LOOKING --
FOR WE CERTAINLY SHARE THE
GOVERNOR'S DESIRE IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S DESIRED INCREASE
HOUSING --
IT'S BEEN ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES FOR THREE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS LEAVE CITIES WE WANT TO
SEE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
WILL SEE THOUSAND ALL INCOME
LEVELS --
BUT WITH THEIR SPECIFIC REGARD
TO SOME OF THE POLLS IN THE BILL
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PLANNING WE'VE YOU
THAT IS IT IS VERY IMPORTANT I'M
COMES ON THE HEELS OF SB TO
FUNDING --
WERE YOU SEE ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS COME OUT THE
PLANET IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AND THAT THERE WERE
TWO BILLS IT PASSED THIS
LEGISLATURE BUT A YEAR AGO.
I'M SB A FIVE FORTY IN AB
SEVENTY THREE THOSE BILL
STREAMLINED THE HOUSING APPROVAL
PROCESS YOU FRONT LOAD ALL THE
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW YOU PROVIDE
CERTAINTY TO DEVELOPERS YOU DO
SEEK WERE AND ON THE BACK AND
YOU HAVE BY RIGHT PROPOSALS WERE
USE HAND THEM AN APPLICATOR THEY
GIVE AN APPLICATION.
WE HAVE A PERMIT AND THE
BUILDING OCCURS NOBODY'S USE
THOSE TWO BILLS THAT WENT
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
RELEASE ANY FUNDING SO WE WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S DESIRE TO PUT MONEY
IN THERE --
FOR PLANNING WE'RE GONNA SEE
UNITS BUILT BASED ON THOSE TWO
BILLS IF FOLKS GET MONEY TO DO
THE PLAN ASSOCIATED WITH IT --
BUT WE DO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ARE ARE OF PLANNING
THAT'S GOING TO BE REQUIRED IT'S
A LITTLE UNCLEAR HOW WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN THAT VERY
SHORT TIME FRAME --
SO WE LOOK FOR TO DO SOME
CONVERSATIONS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON THAT BECAUSE IF WE GET
THIS LARGER READ A NUMBER OF FOR
YOU KNOW FOR A COUPLE YEARS.
WE WE WON'T HAVE THE ZONING IN
OUR COMMITTEES NECESSARILY TO
ABSORB THAT SO WE'RE GONNA GO
HAVE TO DO SEQUEL WE'RE GOING TO
MENTOR GENERAL PLAN HOW ARE WE
IN A BILL TO DO ALL THAT IN A
VERY SHORT TIME FRAME.
SO WE CERTAINLY HAVE --
CONCERNS WITH THAT --
BUT ALSO THERE'S THIS
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AND GET BACK
TO CENTER NIELSEN COMMENTS ABOUT
THE THE POLICY PROPOSALS THAT
ARE HERE AND HOW YOU KNOW BIG
THEY ARE AND HOW IT'S MUCH MORE
THAN A TRAILER BILL.
ON THE LANGUAGE IT'S A THE
TRAILER NOW RUN THE COGS ON
THAT'S GOING TO FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
CITIES COUNTIES AND COGS.
AND THAT'S A DISCUSSION I THINK
THAT WE WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO
HAVE A BECAUSE IT'S BEEN VERY
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP NOW --
IN THE FOR GONNA PUT THE COGS IN
A POSITION WHERE THEY HAVE.
YOU KNOW IT CAN SECOND GUESS
ACTIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
THINK THAT'S GONNA COMPLICATE
THAT RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE OUR
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS AND CAN I
CAN SUPERVISORS.
SAID ON THAT VERY CAUGHT SO WE
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT AND
THEN FINALLY THE LINKAGE BETWEEN
HOUSING PRODUCTION OR HOUSING
PLANNING AND ONE DOLLARS.
AND WE DO SHARE THE CONCERNS
THAT THE KIANA MENTIONED ---WE FEEL THAT IT WOULD BETRAY THE
THE VOTERS AND GOVERNOR
COMMITTED WERE THE LEGISLATURE
OF BECAUSE WE NEED MORE HOUSING
SUPPLY AND THERE'S A WAY TO DO
IT -- AND WE
WANT TO TAKE PART IN THAT SO
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'M SURE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS MENTIONED BY PRIOR
SPEAKERS BUT DID ONE ADULT A BIT
A CONTEXT THERE'S A THIRD OF THE
COUNTY STATEWIDE ARE UPDATING
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS DO EITHER
THIS YEAR.
OR IN TWENTY TWENTY SO I THINK
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW THAT
PROCESS WHICH IS KIND OF THE
ONGOING PLANNING PROCESS.
WHICH CONTINUES INTERACTS WITH
THIS NEW SHORT TERM PLANNING
PROCESS OF FOLKS WILL BE HAVING
HIGHER SIX CYCLE NUMBERS VERSES
EVERYONE ELSE WILL HAVE
DIFFERENT SORT OF FIFTH CYCLE
NUMBERS THAT THIS NEW PROCESS.
OUTLINED IN THE TRAILER BILL IS
BASED UPON SO FOR THOSE MOSTLY
RURAL COUNTIES I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION.
I'M WE ALSO ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF PLANNING FUNDING --
FOLKS ARE VERY EAGER TO GET
THEIR APPLICATIONS IN FOR SB TO
PLANNING GRANTS WHICH ARE JUST
ABOUT TO COME ONLINE NEXT MONTH
SO MORE FUNDING --
FOR THOSE IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES
IS OBVIOUSLY HELPFUL FOR
EVERYONE --
ON THE SIDE OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I THINK IN
COUNTY WORLD A LOT OF WHAT WE
REALLY NEED.
AFTER WE DO THAT PLANNING IS
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING SO DO WE
NEED TO UPGRADE A SEWER PLANT OR
BUILD A SEWER PLANT SO WE CAN
HAVE DENSER HOUSING IN
UNINCORPORATED NEIGHBORHOOD.
DO WE NEED TO OFFSET SOME OF THE
OTHER COST SO THAT IT
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULDN'T BE
PROFITABLE MIGHT ACTUALLY BECOME
PROFITABLE WITH THAT INVESTMENT
AND SO I THINK THE FOCUS ON
PLANNING IS GOOD.
BUT IN THE END OF CORPORATE
AREAS ESPECIALLY IN SURE --
IS ALSO NECESSARY --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
UPDATING THE LONG TERM
PRODUCTION GOALS.
WE DO SHARE THE RETICENCE ABOUT
LINKING TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
WITH HOUSING FACTORS THAT ARE
BEYOND LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONTROL
AND APPRECIATE THE PIVOT TOWARDS
PLANNING AND ZONING RATHER THAN
PRODUCTION BUT AGAIN WE WANT TO
BE AT THE TABLE FOR THAT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU.
I I APPRECIATE THE POINT YOU
MADE ABOUT.
SO I APPRECIATE THE POINT YOU
MADE ABOUT OF YOU KNOW
IMPLEMENTATION MONEY SO WITH THE
STORE.
I THINK ANY KIND OF CONNECTION --
IS DIFFERENT FROM JUST GENERAL
PURPOSES IF THERE'S A REAL NEXUS
A REAL CONNECTION SO LIKE YOU
SAID HOUSING.
SO WE NEED.
TO MODERNIZE OR RENOVATE OUR
SEWAGE SYSTEM THAT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME BUT JUST TO USE
IT.
FOR BROADLY SOMETHING ELSE I
SWEAR I HAVE A PROBLEM BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THREE ZERO COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS --
AND POINT OUT THAT --
IN THE WITH THE LA --
WE AGREE THAT REALLY THE EFFORT --
TO FIND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
HELPING WITH PLANNING BUT WE WE
THINK THAT OUR TIME WHEN IN
MONEY AND EFFORTS OF PARTY
BETTER SPENT AT LOOKING AT THE
LONG TERM GOALS AND RINA --
THIS PROPOSAL ITSELF
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT RINA IS FLAWED
AND THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT
AND SO. TO BASS SHORT TERM
PLANNING GOALS ON SOMETHING THAT
WE KNOW IS FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED
AND WE NEED TO REVAMP SEEMS LIKE --
SETTING UP LOCALS --
FOR FOR FAILURE IN STATE WHY
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING --
FOR FAILURE --
ADDITIONALLY OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
BE VERY OPPOSED TO ANY LINKAGE
WITH THAT TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
ESPECIALLY RURAL AREAS WHERE --
OUR ROADS ARE IN.
SERIOUS DISREPAIR AND SOME OF
THE NORTHERN PARTS OF THE STATE
AND SO WE LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT FUNDING CONTINUES AGO
TO TRANSPORTATION.
AND AND ONE OTHER THING THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS HAVING THE
LONG TERM RENO PROCESS
CONVERSATION.
THE ONE THAT'S HOLISTIC AND WE
REALLY START TO DISCUSS --
HAVING THE STATE INCREASE --
WHERE WE ARE --
THE ROAD CONTINUE TO SEE
DEVASTATING WIRE WILDFIRES AND
THE RING IT DOESN'T REALLY TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION --
HOLISTICALLY AND LOOK AT THOSE
AREAS AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO NOT
CONTINUE TO DO.
MORE PRAT HOUSING PRODUCTION
THOSE AREAS THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HER TAMMY HAVE THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA YOU'VE
HEARD ON ALL THE POINTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES I DO WANT TO JUST
MAKE CLEAR THAT URBAN COUNTIES
ONCE AGAIN ARE VERY --
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR LOCAL PLANNING AND
CERTAINLY SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS ABOUT TYING --
HOUSING PRODUCTION OR HOUSING
PLANNING TO SB ONE DOLLARS WE'RE
INTERESTED IN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON COMING UP WITH
SOME SOLUTIONS THAT.
I CAN BE WORKABLE IN THE MOST
POPULOUS AREAS OF OUR STATE AS
WELL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
MOVING
.
TO THIRTEEN I THINK IS.
IT CONFUSING THAT.
V. ANYWAY. THIRTEEN IF THEY
DANIEL IS THE AGAIN WITH THE
EACH CD [inaudible]
ATVS ROLE.
IMPLEMENTING STATE HOUSING LAWS
AND INVOLVEMENT AT THE LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE LEVEL IS KEY
TO EFFECTIVELY ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S HOUSING GOALS.
REVIEW OF LOCAL HOUSING ELEMENTS
INSURERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ADEQUATELY PLAN TO ME EXISTING.
AND PROJECTED HOUSING NEEDS AND
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSING FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
IN ADDITION RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION EXPANDS EIGHTIES
ROLE NOT JUST REVIEWING BEEN
FORCING JURISDICTIONS COMPLIANCE
WITH THEIR OWN HOUSING ELEMENTS.
IS THE REQUEST ONE MILLION THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE
MILLION TWO HUNDRED FORTY ONE
THOUSAND AND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND IT ALREADY. FOR AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT HOUSING ELEMENT
REVIEW POSITIONS FUNCTIONS FOR
THE UPCOMING SIX CYCLE HOUSING I
HELD HOUSING ELEMENT REVIEW
PERIOD.
ANTICIPATED TO BEGIN.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE WILL NOW
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE DURING THE PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
NO -- I HAVE --
WOMEN.
NO COMMENTS NO.
COMMENT OKAY.
UGH JUST OF IN TERMS OF THE
WORKLOAD.
HOW HAS THE --
THE RINA.
CONVERSATION THAT WE JUST HAD
HOW DOES THAT IMPACT YOUR
WORKLOAD.
WELL THE ALREADY EXISTING LAW
AROUND RENO RIGHT AND SO THE
RENO PROCESS.
YOU KNOW CREDIT PRETTY PROCEEDS
RIGHT THE THE HAVE THE NEED FOR
A HOUSING ELEMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE ALREADY GIVEN.
SANDBAG THE ARENA FOR THE NEXT
CYCLE AND THEN IT KICKS OFF WHEN
THOSE HOUSING ELEMENT OR DO AS
AS MENTIONED THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION THERE HOUSING L. WITH
EVEN COMING DUE.
LATER THIS YEAR --
FOR THIS NEXT CYCLE SO IT IS A
IT IS A PROCESS THAT IS
CONNECTED RIGHT THE DID THE WORK
LOWER TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
ACTUAL REVIEW THOSE HOUSING
ELEMENTS ONCE THEY COME IN.
SO THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT BACK
AND FORTH BASICALLY THERE THEY
ALL COME DO FOR CERTAIN REGIONS
AT THE SAME TIME FOR WHENEVER
THAT REGION APPROVED THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN --
ANDRECEIVED ARENA SO WE HAVE
HUGE PEAKS BECAUSE A GROUP LIKE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SESSIONS
GOVERNMENT'S HUNDRED EIGHTY
CITIES THEY'RE ALL COME DUE AT
THE SAME TIME THERE'S A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH WITH DRAFTS AND
REVISIONS THAT THAT THAT.
TAKES PLACE THERE ARE A LOT OF
DECISIONAL NEW --
NEW LAWS THAT NEED TO BE
COMPLIED WITH AS WELL AND SO --
WE WILL PROCEED RIGHT WITH THE
THE CURRENT LAW --
WITH THAT RENO PROCESS THAT IS
THE STATE SET IN STATUTE --
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THE OTHER
AT NEXT ITEM RIGHT THERE THERE
ARE SOME ACTION YOU LAWS AFFECT
THAT RENO PROCESS IN OUR ABILITY
TO LOOK AT THE METHODOLOGY THAT
OCCURRED AT THE COUNCIL
GOVERNMENT.
LEVEL AND SO THAT IS OUR STATE
LAW AS WELL.
SO -- REALLY
IS THIS IS ABOUT OUR WORK LOAD
IT'S GONNA COME IN BASED ON THE
EXISTING LAW IN OUR HOUSING
ELEMENT.
CENTER DID NOT RENDON I'D LIKE
TO ADD THAT WE ENVISION THAT
THIS WILL WORK WITH THE NEW
PROCESS --
H. CD HAS A ROLE IN REVEALING
THE HOUSING ELEMENTS AS AS ACT
IDENTIFIED --
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE AN ONGOING NEED FOR THESE
POSITIONS AND WE CAN WRITE SIZE
ONCE WE HAVE WITH THAT
ADDITIONAL PROCESS.
LOOKS LIKE IN A FEW YEARS AND IT
JUST EMPHASIZE ITS CURRENT
WORKLOAD SAT BASED ON CURRENT
LAW [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SENATE OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY APPRECIATED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NOW WE GO ON TO ISSUE.
FOURTEEN THE REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ALLOCATION PROCESS ALSO
KNOWN AS THE ARENA DETERMINES
THE AMOUNT OF INCOME
DISTRIBUTION OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CAPACITY EACH
SITTING COUNTY LAST KNOWN OVER
FIVE TO EIGHT YEAR PLANNING
PERIOD.
AND IS INCLUDED IN EACH
JURISDICTIONS HOUSING ELEMENT.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY IN THE
RING ALLOCATION PROCESS AND
PROVIDES JURISDICTIONS AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ACCESS TO MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW RENOWNED
CATIONS ARE CALCULATED.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
AS METHODOLOGY REVIEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR A CD IN THE
RENO PROCESS.
THE CITY IS REQUESTING TO
POSITIONS.
SB.
EIGHT TWENTY WE'RE REQUESTING
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE THOUSAND ON
GOING FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
FUND THESE THREE POSITIONS.
AND COMING NO [inaudible]
NOTHING.
QUESTION.
AND HOW DOES THIS RELATE TO YOUR
OTHER REQUEST WITH RESPECT --
TO LOCAL JURISDICTION PLANNING
NEEDS ETCETERA.
THIS IS A SEPARATE THIS IS
COMPLETELY SEPARATE.
SO THIS REQUEST IS BECAUSE WE
PASSED THESE LAW PASSES I'D LOVE
THE SPECIFIC LAWS --
YOUR LAST FALL AND WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT DOES GIVE A CITY AND
STATE THERE FOR A LITTLE MORE --
ENFORCEMENT OR REVIEW AUTHORITY
OVER -- THE
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS --
ALLOCATION OF RENO AS WELL AS
BILLS AND SOME ADDITIONAL
METHODOLOGY THESE TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN THOSE THINGS
WHEN WHEN THE ACTUAL.
RINA NUMBERS ARE DEVELOP SO.
I THINK PEOPLE MAY KNOW THIS BUT
LIKE THE RENO ACTUAL READING
NUMBERS WE GIVE THEM TO THE
LARGE REGION THERE THEN
DISPERSED AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
AND SO THESE BILLS RESPONDED TO
I THINK --
FROM CRITICISM AROUND HOUSE SOME
OF THE PROPHECIES HAD WORKED.
US IN EQUITY AND HOW THIS
DISTRIBUTION SAID.
AS OF NOW --
AT THE REGIONAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL
THEY WILL --
HAVE TO KIND OF DEFEND THOSE
NUMBER METHODOLOGY WE NOW GET
THE ABILITY TO REVIEW THAT
METHODOLOGY MAKE SURE IT IS
SOUND.
SO THE IDEA HERE IS WE SHOULD --
REDCE THOSE INEQUITIES THAT
OCCURRED --
THROUGH THAT GREATER
TRANSPARENCY SO THERE IS --
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK LOVE YA WE
ALREADY DO RIGHT IN THE BILL THE
NEED TO REVIEW THAT THOSE AND
AND DEVELOP THOSE KIND OF
METHODOLOGY SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
THAT PROCESS I DO AMERICAN WILL
BE SOME.
BACK AND FORTH WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE --
ANGLE AND WE ALREADY OF COURSE
ARE ENGAGING WITH THEM ON ON HOW
THESE ON WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS
ARE CAUSES ARE OF COURSE ALREADY
IN LAW.
OKAY SO WE PASS THE LAWS AND I I
DON'T.
IN IT BUT EVEN BETTER NOW RIGHT.
WE PASSED A NEW LAW IN.
NEW LAWS SO I GOT THAT PART.
OKAY SO YOU KNOW WE WE MODIFY
OUR WORKLOAD RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
STATE LAWS OF JANUARY FIRST --
BUT CERTAINLY THERE'S ADDITIONAL
WORK LOAD IN ORDER TO FULLY
FULLY SEE THE VISION OF THESE AN
ON GOING BASIS --
AND WE WILL GET HIT WITH A LOT
OF THE NEED TO REVIEW A LOT OF
THESE A SHORT TIME THESE COME IN
ALL AT ONCE AND CERTAINLY AN ON
GOING YOU TO ASSIST --
ASSIST REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THEIR
OBLIGATIONS LOS.
AT IT.
OKAY.
THEY WORK WITH THE SOME OF LEAVE
ME.
RIGHT NOW IN IGNORANCE NOTHING
ABOUT HER SO.
TIME OKAY --
APPRECIATE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE NUN OKAY THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH --
ISSUE FIFTEEN MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING PRODUCTION THIS REALLY
FOR PRODUCTION [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MIX THE COME HOUSING THE
MEXICAN LOAN PROGRAM WAS CREATED
BY SB TWO WHICH ALLOCATE 15% OF
ON GOING REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION
FEE REVENUES TO CREATE A MIXED
INCOME HOUSING FOR LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
COMPETITIVE LONG TERM FINANCING
FOR NEWLY CONSTRUCTED MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROJECTS
RESTRICTED THE RESTRICTING IS
BETWEEN THIRTY AND 100% OF EVERY
MEETING COME.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO INVEST. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
ONE TIME IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING FOR MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND I JUST WANNA KNOW
YOU THAT CHALLENGE IF A WILL BE
THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
OKAY.
THE COMMENTS.
NOTHING TO ADD OTHER THAN THESE
FINDINGS WHERE DODD ADD FUNDS
FOR KELLY TO FACE EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
SO THERE'S NO PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES.
UNDER THIS MODEL OF LA --
LE THIS PROPOSAL RAISES
QUESTIONS FOR OUR OFFICE ABOUT
HOW FUNDS ARE PRIORITIZED TO
ASSIST IN THE HOUSE IN SPACE.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT NEED ASSIST --
TIES THE NEED OF THE LOWEST
INCOME INDIVIDUALS IN THE
CITIZENS OF THIS PUSHES THE
INCOME LEVELS UP IN SUPPORT OF
BROADER BROADER SCOPE OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION.
A GIVEN THE UNMET NEEDS THAT
REMAINS FOR THE LOWEST INCOME WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE --
ACCORDINGLY [inaudible]
YEAH.
NO THIS JUST ILLUSTRATES A NEED
THAT THIS IS.
SORT OF SELF REFLECTION OF FOR A
A CHART TO EXPLAIN.
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR THE
LOWEST INCOME?
INDIVIDUALS WHAT WE'RE DOING
HOMELESSNESS WHAT WE'RE DOING
FOR MODERATE.
LEVELS OF THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
THAT EXIST THIS IS YOU DON'T
NEED TO RESPOND TO THIS IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT --
ALL.
PERHAPS IF YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT TO EXPLAIN ALL THAT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL.
I THINK THAT'S A GREAT IDEA A
GROUP.
CAN JUST GET.
GET STUCK IN A LOT OF SQUARES
WITH MONIES AND THEN NOT KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IT ADDS UP.
TO DEPARTMENT FINANCE I DON'T
KNOW THE WE HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT PREPARED BUT IF WE DO A
CHECK AND I'LL HAVE TO SEND THAT
OVER TO STAFF.
I REMEMBER ONCE --
AND THE UNITED WAY BOARD TALKING
ABOUT HOUSING NEEDS AND AND LA
COUNTY.
AND IF THERE WAS INFORMATION WE
GOT INFORMATION ABOUT.
THAT PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
WASN'T.
WASN'T AIMED AT MODERATE.
INCOME LEVELS --
AND THERE WAS ACTUALLY I WAS
MORE STAGNATED THAN EVEN THE
PRODUCTION OF LOW INCOME THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THERE'S A
GREATER NEED.
AT THE LOW INCOME LEVEL BUT I
REMEMBER THAT WAS THAT WAS A BIT
OF A SURPRISE TO ME WHAT I I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS.
REALLY WHAT'S THAT NEED AND SO
MAYBE I WHY WOULD BE FOCUSED ON
MODERATE INCOME.
I I KNOW GENERALLY BUT NOT
SPECIFICALLY WHY WOULD WE MAKE
THAT A PRIORITY.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING NOW IT'S
MORE BECAUSE YEAH EVEN EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE NOT THE
ADMINISTERING ENTITY OF THIS
SPECIFIC PROGRAM --
YOU KNOW IT STARTED WITHIN THE
CONVERSATION AND SENATE BILL TWO
CENTER AS AN AMERICAN THE BILL
ON THE FROM A SOURCE BILL SO
THAT ALLOCATED 15% TO ADDRESS
KIND OF MIDDLE INCOME NEEDS THIS
WOULD NOT GET AUGMENTATION FOR
KIND OF THAT APPROACH --
EM.
THIS VERY HIGH LEVEL MOST
PROGRAMS BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
ARE RESTRICTED AT SERVING LOW
INCOME FOLKS AT ANFIELD BELOW 6% --
VERY MEDIAN INCOME BUT THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE OF COURSE STRUGGLING
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE GIVEN HIGH
COST HIGH RISING COSTS --
TRADITIONALLY NO MIDDLE CLASS
TEACHER FIVE FIVE SIX CETERA
THEY CANNOT LIVE WHERE THEY WORK
THAT IS PART OF THE ARGUMENT
BEHIND A CERTAINLY --
IT IS COMPLEMENTARY TO SOME OF
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGET LOW INCOME
HEALTH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SURE MEMBERS THIS IS A TANKER
AGUMBE HOPEFULLY GET CALIFORNIA
CITIES --
WE'RE SUPPORT OF THIS --
PROPOSAL --
FOR FOR FUNDING MORE MODERATE IN
THE OHIO SO REPRESENTATIVE
POINTED OUT THERE CERTAINLY ORAL
MANY NEEDS OF FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE.
OF THIS SUB PROPOSITION ONE AND
AN AXE AND ACTUALLY PROPOSITION
TWO AND SOME OF THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE JUST COMING ONLINE IT'S
REALLY BEEN ABOUT A DECADE SINCE
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD REALLY MUCH
AT ALL TO WORK WITH.
A INCLUDING WITH THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT.
THE MORE RESOURCES ARE COMING ON
LINE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING MORE
RESOURCES BUT A LOT OF THE FOCUS
AT LEAST ON THE POLICY FOCUS IN
THIS BUILDING IS IS THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT THE IT IS
CERTAINLY THE THE ABILITY FOR
WORK FORCE HOUSING --
CERTAINLY AND ALONG OUR COAST
LINES WE HAVE REALLY HIGH DOLLAR --
LAND VALUES OF WORKER SEARCHES
AND HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED WITH
THEIR TEACHERS --
OTHER OTHER --
HIGH TECH WORKERS OTHERS HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF CHALLENGES A
LIVING WHERE THEY WORK.
THE SOME OF THOSE --
INDIVIDUALS MANY OF THEM DO NOT --
THAT THEY MAKE MORE THAN AND SO
HAVING SOME KIND OF RECOGNITION
OF THIS --
THIS THIS ISSUE OF WORK FORCE
HOUSING SOMETHING THAT'S OFTEN
DISCUSSED IN THIS BUILDING AND
HAVING SOME RESOURCES --
DIRECTED TOWARD THAT WE THINK IS
APPROPRIATE --
AND END AT LEAST --
ADDRESSES ONE PORTION OF OF A
NEED IN THIS STATE WHICH WE
THINK OFTEN HAS NOT NOT REALLY
BEEN FULLY ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
[inaudible] SIXTEEN SIX SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT TIME CHAPTER SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE AFFECTED TO THOUGHT
OF AND FOURTEEN ALLOWED LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO CREATE ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS.
WHICH AUGMENT THE TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING POWER IS AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UNDER EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT STATUTES.
THESE EF IDEAS ARE ALLOWED TO
ISSUE DEBT UPON 55% VOTER
APPROVAL HOWEVER ONLY THREE I.
F..
E. I. F. THESE HAVE BEEN FORM
SINCE THE STATUTE WAS CREATED
WITH RENDON'S VALVE VALUABLE WAY --
TO ENCOURAGE PRODUCTION AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE BELIEVE
THAT MOVING THE 55% BUT A
THRESHOLD AND MAKING CONFORMING
CHANGES TI THE LAW WILL
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF THIS
PROVISIONS MAY BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
YES WE WOULD.
SO ON THIS ISSUE AND THEY NOTED
TO US THAT THERE IS SOME
AMBIGUITY ABOUT WHETHER THIS
PROPOSAL IS IN CONFLICT WITH THE
DEBT CLAUSE OF THE CONSTITUTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHRIS STILL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
IN REFERENCE TO THAT I JUST LIKE
TO KNOW THAT --
WE REVIEWED LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S CONCERNS AND WE'VE
ALSO LOOKED AT THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE OPERATIVE PROVISIONS
SECTION.
SIXTEEN ARTICLE ANNOUNCER
ARTICLE SIXTEEN SECTION.
EIGHTEEN WHICH STATES IN
RELEVANT PART.
FIND IT HERE.
SAYS NO COUNTY CITY TOWN
TOWNSHIP BOARD OF EDUCATION OR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SHALL OCCUR ANY INDEBTEDNESS
RELIABILITY WITHOUT THE ASSENT
OF TWO THIRDS OF THE VOTERS.
AND THE COURTS HAVE HISTORICALLY
INTERPRETED THAT AS BEING
STRICTLY CONSTRUCTION THIS IS
APPLYING ONLY TO COUNTIES CITIES
TOWNS TOWNSHIPS BOARD OF
EDUCATION SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SO CONSEQUENTLY --
IT IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FORMALLY THE TWO THIRDS VOTE
PROVISIONS NOT APPLY TO ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS.
AND SIMILARLY WHEN --
WE CREATED THE I HAVE TO USE AND
STATUTES.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE THE
PREDECESSOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS REQUIRED A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
AND THEN THE AYE ABUSE REQUIRED
55% VOTING LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
EXPRESSED THE SAME CONCERNS THAT
THE NOT PREVENT THE LEGISLATION
GOING FORWARD TO REQUIRE A 55%
VOTE FOR THE ISPS.
AND CONSEQUENTLY AGAIN THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT
WE SEE THAT REQUIRES HER TO BE
ANY BOAT REQUIREMENT WHATSOEVER.
FOR THE STATE ISSUANCES.
GREAT SOFT BY UNDERSTAND THIS SO
THAT THE E. L. D. I. F. D..
CAN INCUR DEBT RIGHT YES SIR.
OKAY -- IN
THE E. F. I. D. IT KERR IS THAT
AND AND HAT DEBT THEN IS
ULTIMATELY ON THE TAXPAYERS BACK
IS THAT RIGHT YES IT'S SIMILAR
TO THE FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES RIGHT IS --
FITS TAX INCREMENT FINANCING SO
IT'S NOT LIVING IN NEW TASKS
ACTUALLY YOU CREATE THE IMPRINT.
TO IN THE PROJECT AREA IN THE
PROJECT RECEIVE THE INCREMENTAL
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX AND CURSE
WITHIN THAT PROJECT AREA THAT
USES THAT INCREMENTAL GROWTH TO
PAY THE DEBT SERVICE ON THE DEBT
THAT IT ISSUES.
SO IT'S NOT A NEW TAX LEVY PER
SE ON THE VOTERS IS JUST A
SWEEPING INCREMENTAL GROWTH AND
PROPERTY TAX BUT OF A CITY DID
THE EXACT SAME THING.
THAT WOULD BE A VIOLATION THE
CONSTITUTION IT WOULDN'T AND THE
CITY CONTROLLED CITY CREATED
ENTITIES SUCH AS JOINT POWERS
AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE TO ACTUALLY
GET VOTER APPROVAL FOR DEBT
ISSUANCES.
BUT THE CITY ITSELF DOES.
OKAY BUT THESE ARE STATE CREATED
I'M THESE ARE CREATED BY LOCAL
ENTITIES CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
AUTHORIZED TO CREATE THEM.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS A
PARTNER THE OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES --
EXCEPT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE NAY PARTNER TOGETHER TO
ACTUALLY COME UP WITH A
FINANCING PLAN AND CONTRIBUTE
TAX TO THE FINANCING.
SO LET'S COUNCILS OKAY WITH THIS
NOW -- BOWL
I THINK LEAD COUNSEL IN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT ON THE
INTERPRETATION OF SECTION --
SIXTEEN ARTICLE ARTICLE SIXTEEN
SECTION --
EIGHTEEN WE RESPECTFULLY THINK
THAT -- THAT.
WE DON'T AGREE WITH THEIR
INTERPRETATION.
THAT'S OUR IN CHINA AS WELL THAT
LEDGE COUNCIL --
FEELS THAT.
HE WOULD BE IN THE SPACE THAT
THE CONCERT A COMMUNICATED TO
OUR OFFICE IS THAT BECAUSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE PLEDGE JEAN
SENSUALLY THEIR PROPERTY TAX.
TOWARDS THE DEBT TO SORT OF BACK
THAT THAT THAT THAT YEAH IF
THESE ARE TAKING ON THAT IT
WOULD BE CAPTURED BY THIS
PROVISION OF THE CONSTITUTION.
THE BECAUSE NONE OF THE THERE'S
ONLY A FEW EFT IS IN EXISTENCE
AND AS FAR AS WE KNOW NONE HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN ON ANY BOND AT
THAT HASN'T BEEN CHALLENGED.
AND SO THEY'RE JUST FLAGGING
THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR
CONFLICT HERE.
YOU KNOW JUST KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
TO USE A VERY SIMILAR TO THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
WAS ALSO DID NOT REQUIRE VOTER
APPROVAL TO ISSUE.
SO WHAT THE INTO MAYBE THIS IS A
CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER TIME
AND PLACE SO WHAT HAPPENS IF ONE
OF THE E. F. ID'S.
ENCOURAGED THAT SOMEBODY'S GONNA
SOON RIGHT.
THE MINUTEIT THERE'S AN
AMBIGUITY SO THUS WE WE WE
RESPECTFULLY --
WOULD DISAGREE OF WHAT THERE'S
AN AMBIGUITY ON SOME COULD
CERTAINLY.
A TAXPAYERS CERTAINLY CHALLENGE
THE DENTIST RENTS AS THEY SAW
FIT BUT WE THINK THE BASED ON
THE PRIOR --
BODY OF COURT RULINGS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THE COURTS WOULD
DISMISS THAT CASE.
BECAUSE AGAIN THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT.
SECTION TOM ARTICLE SIXTEEN
SECTION EIGHTEEN ONLY APPLIES
THOSE SPECIFIC ENTITY YOU DON'T
EVEN AGREE THERE'S AN AMBIGUITY
WE DON'T WE WE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH WHAT COUNSEL
THERE'S AN AMBIGUITY.
OKAY BUT LET'S ASSUME THAT LEDGE
COUNCILS JUST.
JUST INDULGE MY WRONGFULNESS FOR
SECOND -- SO.
THAT LEDGE COUNCIL BELIEVES IS
AMBIGUITY LET'S ASSUME THE LEDGE
COUNCILS RIGHT THERE THAT THERE
IS AN AMBIGUITY IN SO ONCE THE
TEST THAT THE COURT.
WHAT WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN IS
IS WHAT HAPPENS SO?
A. D. F. I. D. ENCOURAGED THAT --
WHAT WHAT WHAT THEN HAVE WHAT'S
THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE LAWSUIT
WHILE IT'S PENDING?
GOT SORT OF THE CERTIFIED DEED I
WOULD HATE TO SPECULATE ON THAT
IF.
IF SOMEONE WERE TO SUCCESSFULLY
CHALLENGE BUT DEBT ISSUANCE
AFTER THE CURTAIN COURTS FOR
DISABLED YOU'RE TOTALLY WRONG
SECTION NOT NOT EVEN CONCERNED
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S SUCCESSFUL
WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN IS THE
PERIOD OF TIME WHILE THE LAWSUIT
IS PENDING WHAT I THINK DURING
THE PENDENCY THE LAWSUIT THAT
THEY WOULD.
STILL BE ABLE TO COLLECT TAX
INCREMENT FINANCE THAT ON
JUNCTION MAIN LESSER IS AN
INJUNCTION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY. FOR LEAVE IT OPEN THE OPEN
A OKAY THANK YOU --
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
YOU'RE CURED WITH WE GET
CALIFORNIA CITIES --
FIRST OF ALL WE DO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL OR BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ACTUALLY DO
AGREE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES ANALYSIS THERE WAS A
LOT OF ANALYSIS OF THIS ISSUE
ESPECIALLY IN THE WAKE OF OF THE
LOS REDEVELOPMENT OF JUST WHAT
THE OPTIONS WERE GOING FORWARD --
I I THINK WHAT PROBABLY WILL
HAPPEN IN MANY CASES IS BEFORE --
THEY'LL ISSUE DEBT --
THEY'LL PROBABLY WANTED TO DO A
VALIDATION ACTION I MEAN THAT
pGET THE ANSWER --
TO THIS IS --
IT AND IT BUT WE DO WHAT WE'VE
ALWAYS FELT THAT THE 55% VOTE IN
THIS LAW --
WAS IT NECESSARY AND EASIER SO
FOR THIS REASON WE WOULD SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN CAL HOME PROGRAM
CHANGES.
THE CALHOUN PROGRAM PROVIDES
GRANTS AND APPROPRIATE FUNDS TO
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUAL FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS TO DEFERED PAYMENT LOANS
FOR DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE HOME
REHABILITATION.
INCLUDING MANUFACTURED HOMES NOW
ON PERMANENT FOUNDATIONS
ACQUISITION REHABILITATION ON BY
COUNSELING SO FELT MORTGAGE
ASSISTANCE OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SELF HELP
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
FUNDS ARE LOAN FROM GRANT
RECIPIENTS TO INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS.
DEMONSTRATION AS PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
THE PROGRAM TO INCLUDE A THREE
DWELLING UNITS IN JUNIOR SAYS
REACH ONE UNITS.
AND AUTHORIZED THE PROGRAM TO
MAKE GRANTS FOR HOUSING PURPOSES
AND DECLARED DISASTER AREAS.
WITH THAT WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
I KNOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M AND CRYSTAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU'RE GOING TO KILL FORTY
CITIES TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVE ON THEN.
OF ISSUE EIGHTEEN LOCAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND.
THE LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FROM
PROVIDES MATCHING GRANTS TO
LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUNDS THAT
ARE FUNDED ON AN ONGOING BASIS
FROM.
THERE ARE NONE OF THE RISE
RESTRICTION RESTRICTED IN THE
USE FOR HOUSING PROGRAMS.
PRINT LEGIBLE RECIPIENTS INCLUDE
CITIES AND COUNTING'S WITH
ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENTS THE
CITY IS THE CHAIRMAN TO COMPLY
WITH HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
INSURABLE.
WILL STRUCTURE WILL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUND TO MAKE
MATCHING GRANTS MAEVE AMERICAN
TRIES AND TO INCREASE.
THE MINIMUM SIZE OF AWARDS TO
VARIOUS LOCAL TRUST [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NOTHING [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY.
JUST ONE QUESTION DO THESE --
THESE ARE OF THE MONEY GOES TO
THE MUNICIPALITY OR AN
ORGANIZATION CAN YOU JUST
DESCRIBE EXPLAINED A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH THEY'RE TOO OLD BOB IF YOU
CAN BE A A CITY OR COUNTY OR CAN
BE A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
AND IN GENERAL THEY ARE.
THEY THEY THEY HAVE THE OPTION
OF FINDING A VARIETY OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PEOPLE BECOME OR REMAIN
HOMEOWNERS.
AND THEY MAKE THE CITY OR THE
NONPROFIT AND WORKS WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS WE DON'T
DO THAT FROM SACRAMENTO WITH
INDIVIDUAL PERSON SO WE HAVE
THIS INTERMEDIARY WHICH IS THE
CITY FOR THE NONPROFIT.
AND THERE IS NO IT IT'S NOT
BASED ON GEOGRAPHICAL AREA I
MEAN.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
YOU KNOW THESE LOANS ARE
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE STATE OR
WHERE MOST NEEDED HOW HOW DOES
THAT HAVE WE'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND
EVERY SITTING COUNTY THE FUNDING
IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO TO FIND
EVERY JURISDICTION AND AND NOT
EVERYONE APPLIES AND NUMBER OF
CITIES CAN YOU DON'T RUN THEIR
OWN.
SORT HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS
NECESSARILY OF BUT WE WE IN THE
COMPETITION WE DO HAVE SORT OF
THE GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDS.
IN OR TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT.
A GOOD AMOUNT IS A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SORT OF RURAL AREAS AND SO WE DO
HAVE THESE GENERAL GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF PARAMETERS.
BUT IT IS THAT WE DO NOT WE
CANNOT FUND EVERY SITTING COUNTY
THE FUNDS ARE JUST INSUFFICIENT
FOR THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO IT'S OKAY --
AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
TO JUST NOW BE INCLUDED AS AN
ENTITY THAT YOU COULD.
GIVE A GRANT.
TO ACTUALLY BUT I THINK I
THOUGHT YOUR TYPE OF THE CALHOUN
PROGRAM WHICH I REALIZE NOW IS
PROBABLY. TO TO ITEMIZE BEFORE.
I'M RIGHT OKAY LOCAL HOW THE
JUST AND MY MY MISTAKE AT LOCAL
HOUSING TRUST FUND.
IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FIRST
OF ALL --
THE WAY THE IT IS THE IT IS
GENERALLY A CITY OR COUNTY THAT
APPLIES ALTHOUGH IT CAN BE A
NONPROFIT AS WELL THAT OFTEN IS
SORT OF AN OFFSHOOT OR CITY
COUNTY BUT THEY THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE AN IDENTIFY REVENUE
SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND WE ARE SORT OF MATCHING THAT
RIGHT SO HERE'S THE ELIGIBILITY
IS NOT JUST TO BE A CITY CAN OR
NONPROFIT BUT IT IS ONE THAT HAS.
YOU KNOW IDENTIFIED A A NEW
RESIDENCE OR SO CITY FOR EXAMPLE
THE CITY AND COUNTY SACRAMENTO.
HAVE A COMMERCIAL LINKAGE FEE
WHEN.
WHEN COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS ARE
BUILT THE COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
DEVELOPER PAYS A CERTAIN AMOUNT?
THAT HELPS THEN SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
WORKERS WILL BE WORKING IN THAT
BUILDING SO THAT'S A DEDICATED
REVENUE SOURCE AND WE'RE THIS
PROGRAM THE IDEA OF IT IS TO
ENCOURAGE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND OTHERS TO
SORT OF CREATE THESE NEW SOURCES
WILL HELP YOU MATCH IT.
THERE ARE SOME INSTANCES WHERE
THEY ARE NON PROFITS OF LIKE A
COUNTY LEVEL BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
FAIRLY UNUSUAL --
AND THEN AGAIN THEY WOULD THEN
ADMINISTER THE MONEY AND THAT
MONEY CAN GO FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP
OR RENTAL HOUSING SO UNLIKE CAL
HOME WHICH IS JUST HOMEOWNERSHIP
THE LOCAL TO TRUST AND SOME OF
RIDE IF USES IF THEY CAN PUT THE
MONEY.
TO THAT'S IT THE A SO HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT YOU WILL
NOW INCLUDE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES SO CORRECT SO FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE OR TO CREATE ITS
OWN FUNDING SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THAT'S
NOT ALREADY REQUIRED TO BE SPENT
FOR HOUSING.
WE COULD MATCH THAT.
WITH THE TRIBE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY --
PUBLIC OF PUBLIC COMMENT I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T SORRY SIR SORRY I
HAD.
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION TO A
MILITARY FELLOW WHO'VE LOST ALL
OF HIS PROPERTY IN THE PARADISE
FIRE.
AND I'D GIVEN IN THE SENATE
RESOLUTION.
AND HE CAME DOWN.
TO GIVE IT BACK TO US OR GIVE
HIM A NEW.
ONE EXCUSE ME.
THE L.. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
ANY YET MAYBE IT CAME UP AND I
MISSED IT BUT HOW MANY UNITS
WOULD WE BE PROJECTED TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THREE HUNDRED
MILLION.
THAT'S A VERY DIFFICULT THE
QUESTION ANSWER BECAUSE THE
LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUNDS HAVE A
LARGE --
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
USE THESE FUNDS IT CAN GO FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP PICKING GO FOR
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING.
AND YOU KNOW HOW MUCHTHEY END
UP SPENDING PER UNIT THAN.
IS THIS SORT OF UNKNOWABLE UNTIL
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
YEARS USES ARE GOING TO BE SO --
I HAVE A HARD TIME PREDICTING AN
EXACT NUMBER THAT AS A THAT READ
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
BONTA [inaudible]
TEEN.
ON AUGUST TWENTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
ANNOUNCED THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE TWO
HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION TO
SUPPORT LONG TERM RECOVERY AND
MITIGATION EFFORTS RELATED TO
THE OCTOBER AND DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES.
FUNDS WERE APPROPRIATED FOR BOTH
OMIT RECOVERING NEEDS A
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES AS FOLLOWS.
TWO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
MILLION FROM IT RECOVERY NEEDS
IMMEDIATE MILLER FOR
PREPAREDNESS IMITATION NEEDS.
THIS BUDGET CHANGEABLE THE
SURPLUS POSITION IN BUDGET
AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION AMERICA RE
NEEDS QUESTION OF THIS FEDERAL
GRANT.
SPECIFICALLY AC REQUEST. EIGHT
MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IN TWO
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND ONGOING FROM THE
FEDERAL TRUST FUND. FOR TEN
POSITIONS TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT THE ON IT RECOVERY.
BUDGET AUTHORITY TO MANAGE THE
PORTION OF THE GRANT DEDICATED
TO MEDICATION ACTIVITIES WILL BE
ADDRESSED IN A SEPARATE PROPOSAL.
THAT ONE SIR [inaudible]
COMMENTS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
NO.
JUST ONE QUESTION --
HE SAID THAT THE HUD HAS NOT
RELEASED DETAILS.
ON THE EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS DO YOU HAVE.
ANY IDEA WHEN WE COULD EXPECT.
NOT SPECIFICALLY BUT MY STAFF
TOLD ME THAT THEY DO EXPECTED
FAIRLY SOON I DON'T HAVE A RANGE
OF WHAT THAT MEANS.
BUT THEY DO EXPECT IT'S COMING
OUT RELEASE.
FAIRLY SOON I WE CAN WE WE HAVE
A HARD TIME PROTECTING HER
[inaudible]
SCHEDULE.
ALL RIGHT --
WE GOT.
TWENTY OKAY ISSUE TWENTY ONE WE
ALREADY DID A ISSUE --
TWENTY SORRY SORRY ISSUE
NINETEEN PUBLIC SERVICE STORY --
OBVIOUSLY ANCHORED WE KILL FOR
SERVICE AND SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
THE ONE QUESTION WHEN I'VE
READING THE STAFF ANALYSIS IT IT
IT REFERENCES --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DECLARE
DISASTERS AND OBVIOUSLY.
WE'VE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE CITY
OF PARADISE THAT WAS A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIRE SO WHAT'S UNCLEAR
IS IS DUE TO THESE FUNDS CAN
THEY BE USED TO ASSESS --
THE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE AND
OTHERS THAT HAVE SUFFERED
SIMILAR DISASTERS.
IN IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS WORKING ON A
DISASTER PACKAGE FOR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DISASTERS
NATIONWIDE THAT IS NOT YET
FINALIZED THAT THINK IT'S STILL
NEEDS TO GO THROUGH CONGRESS.
SO IT WOULD NOT BE THESE FUNDS
THAT WOULD HELP THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRE VICTIMS BUT WE DO
EXPECT FEDERAL DISASTER FUNDS TO
COME DOWN FOR THAT AND THIS SAME
UNIT WOULD ADMINISTER THOSE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FUNDS AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TWO TWENTY ONE THE
ORGANIZATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIC PLANNING UNIT KNOWN AS
ODST LEADS CONSULTS AND ADVISES
INTERNAL BUSINESS PROCESSES
INNOVATION.
TEAMS TO IDENTIFY CRITICAL
CONSTRAINTS AND BOTTLENECKS THAT
IMPEDE PROCESS AND IMPACT.
CUSTOMERS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
SB TEAM MEMBERS FOCUS ON PROBLEM
SOLVING --
CAUSE ANALYSIS POINT
IDENTIFICATION AND DEPLOYMENT OF
DATA DRIVEN SOLUTIONS THAT CAN
BE QUICKLY IMPLEMENTED.
THE TEAM IDENTIFIES HIGH IMPACT
LOW EVER SOLUTIONS TO DEPLOY
FIRST TO ADDRESS THE LARGEST
PROBLEM IN THE PROCESS.
THE CITY REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FIVE
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND ANNUALLY
TO FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOUR DEMONSTRATED
BUDGET AUTHORITY FOR FOR
POSITIONS JUST --
DSP UNIT.
THIS UNIT WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIC PLANNING
GOVERNANCE EPA PROJECTS AND A
PRICE RISK MANAGEMENT RELATIONAL
CHANGEMENT TRAINING.
AFTER FOUR YEARS EIGHTY INTO
SPACE I'M GOING RESOURCES
TRANSPOSITIONS WILL BE AVAILABLE
FROM OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES
CREATED AS A RESULT OF US.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS COMING COMING
FROM SORRY [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
SURE IT.
PERPLEXING TO ME.
SOMETIMES A REQUEST OF AGENCIES
WERE [inaudible]
MORE STAFF [inaudible]
THIS RELEASE. TO ME TO BE JUST A
NORMAL.
PART OF YOUR DUTIES.
NOT TO BE FUNDED OUT OF WHAT
WE'VE GIVEN YOU WHY WOULD WE
NEED TO GIVE YOU MORE WHAT
WHAT'S NEW AT THAT HAPPENED IT
SO EXPANDED YOUR WORKLOAD
[inaudible]
CHOIRS [inaudible]
MORE.
I JEANINE DOGS NW DIRECTOR OF
AUDIT EVALUATION SO --
JUST IN MY EXPERIENCE IN TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND STATE GOVERNMENT
I DO AGREE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT PROGRAMS AND UNITS SHOULD
BE DOING --
AS OF FORMER MANAGER MYSELF A
LOT OF TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN.
DOING THE WORK PRODUCING THE
WORK AND THEN TAKING THE TIME TO
ANALYZE WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL
CONSTRAINTS WATER THE
BOTTLENECKS WHAT SKINNER --
WHAT SO COMPLEX WITHIN THE
SYSTEM THAT WE CAN'T MEET THE
NEEDS WITH OUR CUSTOMERS?
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT LEADERSHIP
AND MANAGEMENT THEY THE WORK SO
WHAT THIS TEAM HAS DONE AND TO
USE A TERM THATSOMEONE --
AND PREVIOUS SPEAKER USED AS WE
USE THIS TEAM TO KICK START --
THAT PARTICULAR EFFORT AND MOST
OF THE MANAGERS THAT WE WORK
WITHTHEY RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT BUT A LOT
OF TIMES THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE
AND HOW TO START THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO CUT TO CONDUCT THE
ANALYSIS --
THEY ADMITTEDLY ARE VERY USED TO
BAN DATING SYMPTOMS --
AND REACT AND REACTING TO MOST
OF THEM TO LEARN AS YOU WELL
THAT'S WHAT A MAN JUST POST TO
DO.
WHAT WE NEED?
TO TEACH WITH.
THE NAY RUN THAT IN COLLEGE WHO
ARE COMING TO THE THERE ARE
OTHER PLACES.
THAT YOU LEARN THAT.
I GUESS THIS IS SHE FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
CONTINUOUS EDUCATION.
I'M SORRY BE EFFICIENCIES.
I HAVE A OF A QUESTION --
THAT THE YOU'RE SAYING THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET TO THE POINT
WERE.
THERE THE DEFICIENCIES CREATED.
AS A RESULT OF THIS [inaudible]
SOME.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN SO IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH REGARDS TO THE
POSITIONS IS THAT MEAN?
OF HOW DO WE KNOW THE
EFFICIENCIES ARE THERE AND OR
NOT THERE OR YOU COME BACK IN
JUST SAY WELL WE STILL NEED THE
POSITIONS.
SO IN MY EXPERIENCE --
WHEN YOU DO THE DEEPER DIVES
INTO THE BUSINESS PROCESS
ANALYSIS --
YOU'RE ABLE TO IDENTIFY A LOT OF
INEFFICIENCIES IN A PROCESS A
LOT OF WASTE --
SOME OF THE TYPICAL FORMS OF
WAYS THAT WE SEE OUR EXTENSIVE
REVIEW AND APPROVAL PROCESSES --
INEFFECTIVE FILL OUT FORMS THAT
HAVE A LOT OF DEFECTS ON THE
FRONT END BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ANALYZED FOR MANY YEARS AS
FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD --
STAFF OR ACTUALLY SO OUT --
WE LOOK FROM A BUSINESS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT STANDPOINT IT MAKING
INCREMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
CHANGES TO THOSE PROCESSES AND
WHAT IT DOES IS IT --
INCREASES STAFF TIME AND BE ABLE
BEING ABLE TO WORK ON THE HIGHER
PRIORITY WORK AND THAT'S WHAT WE
MEAN BY IDENTIFYING THE FISH --
INEFFICIENCIES --
TYPICALLY WHAT WE DO WHEN WE
STARTUP PROJECT AS WE WE ASK
MANAGERS AND STAFF WHAT ARE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T
GET TO BECAUSE YOU'RE SO BUSY RE
WORKING --
THE THE VARIOUS PROCESSES WITHIN
YOUR YOUR PARTICULAR UNIT OR
AREA AND THEN AFTER THEY REALIZE
AND STREAMLINE SOME OF THE
PROCESSES AND REALIZE THE
EFFICIENCIES.
WE WERE ABLE TO REALLOCATE AND
SHIFT THEM TO THAT PARTICULAR
WORK.
DOES THAT PROCESS --
STOP IN --
WHAT YEAR IS THIS?
DOES THAT STOP IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO I WOULD FAR IS LOOKING FOR
YOU FOR XIN CITIES I UNDERSTAND
WHAT.
WHAT WHAT'S THE WORKLOAD OR WHAT
IS THE SUREST POSSIBILITY THAT
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO DO AND
THEN THOSE EFFICIENCIES SO THEN
THERE'S NO NEED?
FOR THE THREE OR FOUR POSITIONS
SO IF IT MAKES SENSE SO THE UNIT
RIGHT NOW IS SERVING AS LIKE AN
INTERNAL CONSULTANT AND RESOURCE
TO MANAGERS AND STAFF SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE ACTUALLY
TRAINING THE MANAGERS AND STAFF
TO DO THIS WORK THEMSELVES.
IF THAT MAKES SENSE [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I THINK WE'VE COME TO THE END OF
OUR AGENDA [inaudible]
RIGHT.
FINAL.
COMMENTS NO HEARING NONE THANK
YOU EVERYBODY YES SHARE IT ALL
THE TIME THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
WE DID IT WE DID IT.
WE WE WE SHOULD